e
good morning welcome to
Edna uh representative groda is filling
in as our clerk because representative
scitec has had a snow emergency and
won't be in for a bit representative Lon
had a car car emergency and likewise
will not be in for a bit um I'm opening
the public hearing on House Bill 233 and
comto thank you madam chair and thank
you committee members uh for the record
my name is Barbara ktoa representing
belnap 7 Barnstead and New
Hampshire today I'm introducing and I've
put on everyone's desk a possible
Amendment for this um it adds two
additional items to the original bill
but what's we're trying to do is have
more
transparency in our government and the
vaccine
Association which was created via RSA
126q um
is tasked with buying
meetings are held via
zoom and you can go online but once
those meetings are over the only thing
you have left is the
minutes um in today's world with modern
technology I don't think it's a
hard thing to ask about about having
them be online so that the public can
review the other thing with the vaccine
Association if you've ever attended a
meeting is that you can ask questions
but they will not give answers that is
stipulated right up
front they will get back to you but they
will get back to the person so the
question that's asked nobody else knows
what the answer or the reply was I think
it's important for the public
to understand what's going
on this is crucial in this day and age
with so much
controversy
surrounding information regarding
vaccines whether you're for them or
against
them we need to let it be
transparent so that we can gain the
public trust I think having public trust
and transparency and government is
essential so the two other items that
I've added to this bill was one uh to
establish a physical location for a
meeting so people can actually go to the
meeting and not be via Zoom
um I don't know about other meetings I'm
on some commissions and we actually have
physical locations I think it's
important for people to meet in person
and for the public to be able to
attend um the other thing is is asking
for a list of a complete list of all
vaccines and other pharmaceutical
products that they purchase to be listed
we as a legislature and the public who
fund these
programs have the right to know what
we're
buying um and it it's pretty
straightforward so I will be open for
questions thank you are there any
questions from the
committee representative
sellers thank you madam chair so I don't
really know how the anything about the
New Hampshire vaccine
Association uh are they a private
company thank you for asking that no it
was established by the
legislature thank you follow followup
sure thank you again my knowledge is
limited how how many vaccines do we have
maybe like
from kids require from 0 to 18 do you
know I mean we talk in 20 I think the
number is staggering is what I will
leave uh you with that um I know that
when I started in childhood vaccines
there were like five today it's upwards
but there are people here that are more
qualified that I am that could answer
number peerson thank you madam
chair I'm uh I'm not antiva but I have
substantial concerns about some of the
things that have happened in the last 5
years the um the location part of this
I'm I'm not you said this was
established by the
legislature so in the establishment of
this if you know do that include like
mileage for the members does it because
the physical location might incur a cost
I mean just I don't know I don't know
how that was chartered so what is does
that legislative Charter
cover um if you go to 126q colon 3 uh
that's the membership powers and duties
of the vaccine Association I know it was
established to be a not not for-profit
volunteer and it lists the duties it
does not it lists who and what they can
do but it doesn't really say
where they must meet or really there's
not much in there okay so I can't answer
that
question okay can I have a followup
chair it yeah right if it doesn't say
who how does one get on this I I um
thank you representative I may have
misspoke so it does establish who is to
be appointed okay and I guess it doesn't
say where or if they must meet in person
I'm not seeing that in this particular
one but there's someone uh that may be
able to speak to that better than I
thank you you're welcome representative
Howard thank you for taking my question
so I understand that uh the the
association takes some time to get back
to people how long on average does it
take to get back to somebody with a
question um I am not exactly sure but I
believe if they've stated and you know
there there are people here that are
going to speak to that so I don't want
to Mis you know misrepresent them at
this time but you will get that answer
is a representative of the vaccine
Association okay thank you long uh
according to the vaccine association's
handout they don't receive any uh public
inaccurate um thank you for the question
uh they are not for profit they are the
ones that recommend and purchase
vac DHHS is the one with the money for
the actual purchasing of the vaccines
but the vaccine Association I believe is
the one that's determines what
vaccines
followup okay what not represent Argie
yeah thank you
um some of the complaints about this
organization are kind of generic issues
relative to very ious committees and uh
things in New
Hampshire um why did you pick uh choose
to pick on uh the vaccine Association
and not make a generic thing uh
regarding say uh audio and video video
recording of all meetings and published
recordings on the website why not just
make it a generic thing uh thank you for
that question and I would be open to
that Amendment
um because I think that should be
applicable across the board for
everybody okay especially any um you
know subdivision of the political you
know
process however um chairing the special
committee on covid there was a lot of
things that came to light during our
conversations and a lot of things we
didn't know and so for that reason this
members anyone else I oh represent AR
you've got oh representative schmidth
thank you thank you madam
chair first of all question to the chair
is this going to
subcommittee I don't know okay so uh
still up in the air uh now but I'm sure
if it did representative comra would
help thank you um so uh as you know
vaccines are very controversial subject
there's a lot of uh misinformation and
disinformation out there um and there's
a lot of denial of all virtually all
aspects of vaccination and the vaccines
themselves um so when you when you
require an answer uh
um I think it's
a questionable a re requirement since uh
some for some people an answer ain't an
answer it's a a lie or so forth so uh is
that something you've given
consideration to the fact that it's so
contentious well well thank you for that
question representative Schmidt so I
mean I am trusting that when they give
an answer it's truthful it's not
misinformation it is actual information
and we have to respect the the people
that we put in place to give us the
truth okay um we also so I don't
understand why that would be an issue
because I am taking people at their word
in good faith if they're supplying with
it with information if there's a
question if the person has a question of
the information then they can ask that
of of the the
association but that's up to the person
that asked the question I
mean we're always going to have
controversial things where people aren't
going to not going a lot if we don't
like the answer it doesn't mean it's the
wrong
answer okay well thank
you uh representative broa and then
sellers thank you so I've been reading
RSA
126q and one of the requirements is
a annual report so have you read the
annual reports of the commi of the
commission honestly thank you
representative for that I have not
not okay representative
salers thank you madam chair uh if we
decide to go forward and we uh look at
your Amendment on line 21 it it it just
says it says uh showing the brand name
of the shot so my question is are all
vaccines by
shot are they administered in other ways
uh thank you for that for that uh
question and from personal experience
I can tell you that you know the PO for
me personally the polio was not a shot
so um I'm going to say no but I could be
wrong thank you representative law uh
are there any other private entities
that are subject to these requirements
you're proposing in New
Hampshire thank you for the question and
I cannot uh answer that I mean I think
personally that all subdivisions of the
political process should be required to
have all
meetings uh live streamed not only live
edit okay but this one here was focusing
on this particular Association at this
time but my personal opinion is that
they all should
be okay other question representative
re earlier it was stated I'm I want to
make sure that I'm understanding this
correctly it was asked representative
sellers asked about um how many vaccines
were required and I want um to
understand from you when you said many
many more than five I think that you
referenced what when you say the word
required who requires
vaccines I thank you representative re I
think I'm going to let the vaccine
Association discuss that but if you go
on to DHHS there is a childhood
vaccination schedule that is required
for children to enter
school thank you yes the schools are are
primarily The Gatekeepers in that case
other questions thank you very much
thank you madam chair thank you
committee
Association and you should have a copy
written copy of the testimony so they
okay uh good morning uh chairman Maguire
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to present here today
and answer any questions that you may
have um I'm also joined today by the uh
my attorney Mark McHugh who is from
Hinkley Allen he serves as the
association's um longtime Council and if
there's specific questions about 91a Etc
I think he would be the right person to
answer those um just listening to the
questions a minute ago it sounds like
there is definitely some unfamiliarity
with the association and I'll just start
with it is a not for-profit voluntary
Corporation formed under RSA 292 and
then created by State Statute 126q back
in 2002 so more than 20 years ago it was
the first model in the country for
Universal vaccine purchase programs and
their 13 other states currently with
similar programs it's a public and
private partnership in the sense that we
have 80 commercial health insurance
companies and third party administrators
in more than 220 Pediatric and family
care practice locations the New
Hampshire insurance department the
Department of Health and Human Services
as well and what it is is a structural
funding mechanism it does not make
policy we save about 36% projected this
year in fiscal year 2025 and our total
admin costs are less than 1% 84 and
they're born 100% by the commercial
Health insurers and group health plans
administered uh by the
tpas we have an extremely limited role
in the vaccine purchase program that's
managed by the Department of Health and
Human Services the association's sole
purpose is to provide an efficient
funding mechanism for immunizations for
commercially insured children and
children covered by a group health plan
administrated by a thirdparty
administrator and this is under the New
Hampshire's uh childhood Universal
vaccine purchasing program which is
managed by the Department of
Health the association calculates and
collects assessment payments from its
members those of the 80 plus insurance
companies um and it's for children that
are under the age of 19 with those
assessments we remit those funds
directly back to the state of New
Hampshire and uh the state of New
Hampshire uh uses them to defay the cost
of purchases under their program it also
ensures that all healthcare providers
that require access to childhood
immunizations receive them at no cost
whether the patient is primary uh excuse
me privately insured has Medicaid or is
uninsured the association does not
create any vaccine policy we do not
receive state funds and we do not impose
requirements for any
immunizations we are strongly opposed to
House Bill 233 to attempt to subject the
association the proposed requirements
and amendments and Associate
administrative costs outlined in 233 is
unprecedented such a mandate serves no
governmental purpose because the
association is not a public entity
receives no funds from the state has no
power to enact or affect vaccine policy
and is not subject to RSA
91a the association also notes that the
requirements imposed by House Bill 233
would extend far beyond the recoring
reporting requirements of 91a which are
currently imposed on public bodies to
legislate reporting requirements on a
private entity is an unfounded
interference with the governance and
operations of a nonprofit organization
it would impede the ability of the
association performance very limited but
important charitable
purpose the association has voluntarily
adopted uh an expansive public access
policy I'll leave a copy that promotes
transparency WE Post our meeting notices
and agendas in advance on our website
and includes all the meeting minutes any
member of the public can attend any
meeting via webinar which while not
required creates convenience for all
attendees it's also a step above
91a attendance has increased since this
policy was implemented out of courtesy
and transparency the association allows
any member of the public to make
comments at the end of each board or
committee meeting the vast majority of
public comments are related to New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services policies outside of the
association's normal scope narrow scope
of Duties as the executive director I am
always available be by phone or email to
take questions from the public and this
is also stated at the beginning of each
of our meetings and included in all of
our online materials there is no
precedent in state government that I am
aware of for posting questions and
answers from the public on a website
it's not required for house or Senate
committees for example the association
should not become a billboard for policy
statements when it has no policy-making
or policy influencing powers and handles
no public
monies finally in addition to an annual
publicly available Financial audit and
an annual report the association has
multiple public reporting requirements
based upon statute that ensure
accountability we report to the
insurance department the health
department the Speaker of the House of
Representatives the Senate President and
the governor we have Representatives on
our board that are appointed by all of
these entities as well as pediatricians
that're appointed by the Department of
Health and insurance payers who actually
fund all of this work all the reporting
requirements can be found on our public
website in summary we're opposed to this
bill it not only needlessly burdensome
and unnecessary but HB 233 attempts to
impose reporting requirements on a
private entity which interferes with our
performance and our our charitable
purpose while increasing administrative
costs which is born by the payers the
insurance companies thank you for the
opportunity to present the testimony
today I'm happy to answer any questions
that you might have I've also included
my email my phone and uh my mobile
office number thank you representative L
uh are you aware of any other private
entity that is subject to these
requirements and also are you aware of
any public entity that's subject to the
requirement to answer
questions I am not no I'm not no of any
Ru making entity is required to publish
comments and questions from from the
public and their their responses but
issue yes represent powered thank you
for taking my question sure uh so how
long on average does it take for you to
get back to somebody's question sure we
keep a complete log um and we could
calculate that statistic but every uh
email that comes in to us um gets logged
uh at the at the office and then all the
comments that we reply back to um I
would say generally we try to turn
things around in just a few days
sometimes it might take us closer to a
week um often times the information
being requested is coming from the
Department of Health and so we refer
people back to the health department um
because again we're just a financing
mechanism we make no policy you know
decisions but um but I can we could
calculate statistics if you'd like us to
I think pretty easily but um but we do
log everything and respond what I think
is
adequately timely thank you thank you
sure other uh representative Pearson
thank you madam chair you've used the
word transparency in TR in your
testimony so my question revolves around
that sure if you have a zoom meeting yes
which is seems to be the mechanism to
which you guys are are operating um
that's a pretty substantial educational
platform right for your organization to
disseminate
Universe are with this piece of
legislation and the potential Amendment
are you you
opposed
specifically to the part that says the
zoom meetings will just simply be
available to be viewed at a later time
we're currently opposed to all aspects
of the bill primarily due to
administrative requirements and again as
stated priv previously we have an
existing public access policy which we
believe provides adequate um
transparency to the public as well as
reporting that's required by the statute
follow up thank you madam chair
transparency in understanding the
universe we live in here right this this
what we're doing right now is
permanently available on
YouTube
um I think do you so you're telling me
you don't think that this will further
your
mission if you just simply make those
Zoom meetings which are already being
conducted
available later that that does not
further trust and transparency to which
your organization is
functioning sure I'll turn this over to
my attorney just just for the record
good morning my name is Mark McHugh I'm
a partner at the law firm of Hanley
Allen representing uh New Hampshire
vaccine Association for a number of
years um I I think the point is more um
the way the meetings are conducted in
the last portion the association has
voluntarily um opened up the meeting if
there's time to the public for comment
um as Pat as Mr Miller has described the
role of the vaccine Association is
incredibly limited most of that public
commentary goes beyond the scope and
purpose of the vaccine Association um
it's not necessarily accurate
information it's not necessarily
information pertaining to the function
of the association and it's not
something that necessarily would make
sense for the association to respond to
because it's outside its purview so um
it it really doesn't provide
transparency to have that kind of a
record sitting there that it doesn't
pertain to the organization's business
um the the organization is very
mechanical in all of its decisions all
of its processes all of its um minutes
and actually board materials are all
displayed they're part of the permanent
record they're available on its website
and we think that more than uh answers
representative L who makes the rules
about uh what vaccines children are
required to get in order to attend
school uh or in any other situation
where the government may be requiring a
vaccine to participate in some activity
um that's a great question so it it
actually starts at the federal level
with FDA approval and then there's a
committee out of the Center for Disease
and Control uh called asip that then
makes recommendations
and then at that point uh the state
receives those recommendations and the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services has the ability um to
essentially say we want to add this to
something that the program will
basically assess funds for um but
anything uh is really based upon CDC you
know recommendations at the end of the
day the association has absolutely
nothing to do with
that representative Howard thank you I
wanted to call uh kind of follow up on
uh some of the points that
representative Pearson was making uh
would you be supportive of any
administrative rules uh on your end to
uh make sure that your meetings are
uploaded to
YouTube would can I guess we'd have to
consider it but at the moment we don't
think that it's necessary okay thank
you um representative reeze thank you
madam chair if if this were to go
through um you said your administrated
costs currently are less than 1%
yes would this increase the cost to
would your in would your administrative
costs rise yes they would followup
followup thank you um and who ultimately
would bear The increased cost for that
increased administrative burden it would
be the insurance companies that
basically fund the entire Association
again there's no governmental funding
involved here the easiest way to think
about it is we're a pass through
organization so
by allowing this organization to exist
the insurance companies and the state
are purchasing off of a federal contract
that's where that 36% savings comes and
then it allows the vaccines to be given
to 220 provider sites across the state
at no cost and they don't have to bill
for it either so there's no
administrative costs so it was purely
set up for administrative um efficiency
as well as cost savings
oh thank you that's all it does so
ultimately if those costs were then
passed on to the insurance companies
right who do those the insurance
companies pass those costs on be passed
on to the employers who purchase the
products or consumers thank you yeah
represent long you had a question no
okay thank you represent broa yes I have
a question to the
chair so in our calendar this is HB 233
FN but the bill itself is not an FN and
has no fiscal note so if this is going
to have an increase there should be a
fiscal note with this document even
though it's not going to be incurred by
the state wouldn't you think um no I
don't they it if it's called for a
fiscal note it should have one but in
general if there's a cost to the
businesses we don't necessarily count it
as a fiscal note for example the
building code bills have have no fiscal
not followup so why is this an early
question
um he's not here all right thank you
well well I'll take take it on to find
out why early where the fiscal note is
so find out sir if I may ask sure if I
understand you correctly your
organization
merely takes the list of vaccines that
HHS wants to purchase M tells the
insurance companies to Pony up a certain
amount of money correct and then make
sure those vaccines are bought and
distributed exactly but you don't decide
what vaccine are to be purchased just
how many just
who how much each insurer pays based on
their coverage correct ultimately it's a
conversation between the provider and
the patient or in the case of somebody
under the age of 19 the parent would be
involved and the department of uh Health
and Human Services manages all of that
we do not manage any of that so that if
say the Department of Health and Human
Services decided for some reason they
thought was good to require to require
you to purchase flu vaccines y enough to
cover every adult over 65 you would make
arrangements to do so well our
organization is only authorized for
children under the age of 19 we do not
have anything to do with adult
vaccinations at all it's not part of the
statute it's a very limited scope and
the insurers are only paying
proportionally for the covered lives at
Arch children so that it's Equitable in
case one insurer had more adults or
another all right but the the same
principle applies that if the HHS
decided they wanted every child to get a
flu shot you would yes accept that
recommendation and negotiate the price
for for the flu shot so they could be be
free correct not really um so what
happens from a functional perspective is
each summer after the fiscal year has
closed the state provides to us which is
also on our website a list of all the
vaccines that have been purchased and
then a list of what they believe will be
purchased in the next fiscal year our
job is essentially to take that request
and say we need to raise $17.2 million
to you know as a number and our job is
to essentially put the assessment PL
mechanism in place to make sure that
we're charging on a quarterly basis the
insurance companies the right amount to
cover that ask so think of it as just we
get a bill we have to find money to pay
for it and then we pay it that's it
that's as simple a transaction as it is
we have no uh we can't say we don't want
to pay for something we can't say we
would like you to add something that has
it's just outside of our scope it's a
very very limited scope as to what our
role here is all right but the uh some
of the questions you're getting I'm sure
deal with the with policy rather than
they do and those we typically do refer
people back to the Department of Health
and Human Services because we're not we
have no authorization to in statute to
make policy thank you represent Pearson
you had a question yeah I'm uh I'm
trying to we spent half the hearing
talking about what you don't do right
right so I'm trying to understand what
what does a meeting look like for you
what what do you talk about it's very
transactional as attorney McHugh said we
have a separate plan of operation that
the insurance department approves that's
also online um and every single month
there's a prescribed list of tasks that
we carry out it's extremely
transactional most of the time we're
reporting on the financials so how are
we doing in terms are we collecting
enough assessment are we over collecting
um month-to month um and then the bulk
of the work is done in the fall in
September when the board approves the
rate for the coming calendar year um and
there's a package of materials that we
put together to walk through here's the
request that we got here's what we're
seeing for uh the number of covered
lives and then there's a whole
calculation and really the board's job
is to look at that and say it seems
reasonable or not and there's a
subcommittee called the audit committee
that meets twice over the summer to
prepare for that meeting that's
essentially it we don't meet every month
um and uh we choose an auditor every
March that's one other function that we
have and that's about it I can share the
plan of operation electronically if
you'd like it I didn't bring a copy of
that but it lists out by month exactly
what happens including all of our
reporting requirements ments under the
statute so in essence follow up thank
you madam chair sorry uh in essence then
what you're describing to me sounds like
you're just a purchasing agent we're not
even that we are an agent that raises
funds and the Department of Health and
Human Services makes the purchase on
behalf of all children under the age of
19 no matter whether they have insurance
or whether they have Medicaid or
uninsured we have no purchasing
Authority we write we write a check once
a year in
June there's no policy
involved represent BR just out of
curiosity from my own curiosity could
you send us that schedule so that be
happy would be sure and um it's also on
our all of our materials all of our
access polic all of our policies we have
all of our financial audits back to 2002
are also on the website so everything's
there but I'd be more than happy to
email it to the
committee the operation plan I'll send
you the operations manual that would be
I'll do that after be grateful thank you
so muches sellers thank you madam chair
I asked the question earlier is how many
vaccines are we talking about from till
the age 19 um so that's based upon and
I'm not a clinician but it's based upon
a clinical schedule that the CDC
recommends for States um I don't know
the actual number you'd have to ask the
department of health or I could I could
have them send you the schedule but
again I don't make any policy decisions
so I don't know the exact well we're
we're just looking for the number that
you're buying for for this you're
arranging to buy yeah so there are um
why don't I send you the list of what
was purchased last year I think that
would give you and it's in our meeting
materials I'll pull that out and send it
to you as well thank you um this year
than you that would be uh informative
sure and there are different vaccines
have different options as well brand
choice that type of thing so it and I'm
happy to provide that thank you would be
we' be it would be curious sure anything
else represent a Bailey and then
Schmidt you mentioned it $ 1.17 million
is the cost of the vaccines or um so
each year the number changes um for the
coming year the check that we'll write
in June um it's basically a purchase of
between 22 and $24
million followup followup the part
that's confusing me is it doesn't seem
to be claims it's seems to be like a
proactive thing and the state is not
paying and the FEDS are not paying the
insurance companies are paying correct
so they're doing this out of the
goodness of their hearts or they're
doing it for two reasons they hope to
reduce claims in the future or um so I
think there's two reasons for it one is
by par by this program allows the
insurance companies to tap into the CDC
discount and that's where the pricing
differential comes from if they are
purchasing on the public market versus
the CDC price so there's clearly a
financial benefit for the insurance
companies the other benefit more from
the health perspective is that the
provider offices don't have to pay for
the vaccine on their own at a list price
build the insurance company at a higher
price and deal with the whole claims
Administration so the insurance
companies cut out all the claims
Administration which is significant both
for the providers and for the insurance
companies themselves and it just makes
for better clinical care because at the
end of the day no matter what child
walks in if the parent decides that with
the clinician this is the vaccine they
should get they grab it and that's all
they need to do so there's no there's no
administrative overhead if you will to
either the provider or to the payer so
those are the main reasons why the
payers are participating thank you
yes thank you madam chair so uh having
attended a number served on and attended
a number of meetings of City councils
town councils and so forth I know that
it's a common practice that the the
boards that I've attended anyway uh get
questions from the public there's no
question about that but as a general
rule they don't answer uh and very often
it's because they don't have an answer
it's not like what's the sum of X and Y
there's an answer to that that's
immediately knowable uh in many cases
the answer to the question is is not
known and in some cases even not
knowable it could be this it could be
that and and knowledgeable individuals
will argue and debate about whether the
answer is X or Y um and so the boards
generally don't answer uh and and as I
say in many cases the answers are are
not known and so I'm I'm very concerned
about the
workability of the requirement that the
answers be posted within 48 hours or
whatever the particular time frame is um
especially since this is such a
contentious uh uh uh issue and also
we're talking about medicine here and
debating about the efficacy of medicine
is you
know there still many debates about
things we've been using for hundreds of
years so I I I don't see do you do you
consider this to be a workable
Demand on the part of the
statute you wantan yeah I we don't see
it as workable and again we're providing
the ability for the public to comment
anybody who's ly online can listen to
those comments and most of the questions
and comments that we get have nothing to
do with the association itself and we
refer most of them back to the
Department of Health and Human
Services if I could if I could just
clarify or add to um we're not a public
agency
we're not a public body we're not a
quasi public body um we're its creation
was mandated by the legislature in RSA
126q but it's not like a chartered
entity like hospital or a college where
the statute is the charter um the we
were directed to establish a nonprofit
voluntary Corporation under RSA 292 to
adopt articles and bylaws which give um
kind of rule procedural rules so it very
much is not um any kind of public entity
i' I'm familiar with the local
government center firefighters case um
in that case that entity um its sole
members were political subdivisions were
towns from municipalities its board was
governed entirely by Municipal officers
and if um it didn't provide its pulled
Management Programs then the towns would
have to do that individually in this
case in addition to thinking of us as a
a pass through the legislative history
is helpful when the state years ago was
deciding whether to participate in the
federal vaccine children's vaccine
purchase program and make those
discounts available it was reluctant to
commit fully State funds and it wanted
some contribution some participation by
Health insurers and so for the reasons
that Mr Miller explained the health
insurers thought that that made sense
and so this entity is really their
entity to manage their contribution to
the state purchase of vaccines under
that Federal program it doesn't have any
again doesn't have any policy um control
these are funds from these private
entities that are then handed to the
state um so it's it's not a public
entity they're not public monies we're
just not um applying 91a just doesn't
make sense to this kind of enti you'd
have to apply it to every single RSA 292
voluntary Corporation in the state which
I I don't I think is not serving any
governmental purpose thank you for your
response because I think this is very
helpful representative Leon uh thank you
madam chair I apologize for my
tardiness we had a flat tire but I was
watching this by YouTube and I'm very
thankful I can ask you a question um it
sounds like you said a lot of the cost
and reimbursement to make sure that the
insurance companies are paying what's
necessary sorry the the insurance
companies are paying what's necessary
and the providers are able to have these
at no cost do you set the policy around
what providers are charged for unused
vac Vines um when they have say 10
children in their practice and one does
not decides to opt out either from a
religious or other exemption what is the
charge assessed upon that provider if
they have a covered life that does not
use the vaccine so the the charges
aren't assessed to the provider the the
revenue that we receive comes from the
insurance companies not from the
providers so um there's a true up if you
will that the department does during the
year so each month um what what actually
was used what was returned there's a
whole process that the Department of
Health goes through so that by the time
we get to June and we're asked to write
the check back to the department to fund
vaccines for the next year um they've
been able to account for you know if
they potentially had more in stock or
less in stock they they they trew all
that up but there's no there's no
assessment to the provider from the
association I don't I can't speak to the
department but none that I'm aware of
well follow uh so I have been told that
if a provider doesn't use one of the
doses they have to pay to replace that
dose if it goes unexpired not at the
purchased contracted price but at the
list price from the manufacturer is that
part of your um is that anything to do
with what you do in your process it does
not um I believe what you're referring
to is the CDC sets wastage rates for um
uh states that participate in this
program and there if the provider
exceeds those or wastage was caused
either intentionally or something
happened their responsible at the
provider level but that's a CDC that's a
federal state piece the association has
doesn't do
anything regarding that at all it
doesn't impact what we do one last
followup follow and the my sorry my last
followup is basically you are
implementing what the CDC has sent to
the state under the expectation that
that's the policy set by the Department
of Health and Human Services is that a
correct understanding say that one more
time that you're implementing the
directives from the CDC for
participation in this program for
vaccines um subject to your
understanding that the Department of
Health and Human Services has set the
policy choices is that correct yes so
the the Department of Health um as I
explained earlier the FDA approves
vaccines the CDC has an advisory
committee that recommends vaccines to a
schedule the state then can determine
through the Commissioner's Office of
Health and Human Services whether or not
to add that vaccine to the schedule so
ultimately the state determines what
will be on the schedule and won't be and
then we are asked to remit funding for
whatever that schedule looks like at the
end of the day does that help it does
thank you sure representative sers thank
you madam chair and you're going to
provide that list like you said of
vaccines so my my question on that is um
can you you also identify which ones the
HHS purchases because you sell it to
other doctors and places do you sell
only the HHS yeah we don't sell anything
first of all so um just to back up so
the state has what they call a universal
purchasing program for vaccines where
they take Federal monies for uninsured
and Medicaid and they combine them with
private monies that this group The
Association provides the state
determines Year from an estimate
perspective what they think the provider
offices are going to use they then ask
us to fund a proportion of that it's
about
60% and then um they manage signing up
providers that participate in the
program the provider ordering system all
of that is managed by the state um so at
the end of the day there's no
transaction excuse me between the
association and any provider office if
you will um it's all done with just one
check we write at the end of the year to
the state itself and then they they use
those funds to purchase the vaccine so
the providers can order what they need
help follow up yeah thank you I I was
just trying to get an idea of
um if there's if there's 20 vaccines
does HHS
require 18 of them and other doctors are
you know maybe the other two yeah I'd
have to I think you should ask that
question of ghhs directly because that's
a policy question that we're not charged
with our scope is literally to raise
funds and write a check at the end of
the year so um but I'm sure we could
connect you to the office of
immunization um to take that question
back
Y and the and ultimately I mean there
are exemptions and there's other and
it's up to parental choice at the end of
the day so
as I understand it okay thank you other
representative schi thank you madam
chair one other aspect has come to mind
and that is
that I think most vaccines have a best
used by date and so forth a spoilage
date and I know covid some of the covid
vaccines for example uh had to be used
once they were open they had to be used
within a certain amount of time or they
couldn't be used legally
um so does that factor into some degree
or is
thatly internal to the to the entity
that's going to administer the vaccine
um so as part of um the vaccine for
children program which is a federal
program that New Hampshire participates
in there is a c there's a provider
contract that the individual clinician
physician physician assistant Etc who's
receiving the vaccines has to sign and
part of that um is basically stating how
they will manage the inventory so
there's no loss that things are return
before they expire Etc and the
Department of Health and Human Services
immunization group manages that whole
process so they they do on-site visits
of the providers every year they sign
the providers up and they manage the
ordering process with them okay thank
you yep all
DHHS all right other questions thank you
very much Mr Miller okay and I will um I
have a copy of the public access policy
if I could leave that with you now and
then I will email the committee the
operations manual and then from our
meeting minutes what was purchased last
year that's thank you very much thank
wheeler thank you chairwoman McGuire
pars and colleagues on the house
executive departments and administration
committee uh for the my name is
representative Jonah oion wheeler I
represent the towns of Peter bro and
Sharon I'm here today generally in
support of the idea that we would film
the audio and video of this board and I
don't have much else to say other than
that there are other people who can
testify more in support but the idea
that people can join the meeting via
Zoom read the minutes online access all
these different ways that the prior test
to fire said that they could access
through but in the 21st century we
wouldn't film the audio and video is
just a little silly to me uh people when
it was proposed by uh representative
Kirk uh not so long ago some of you may
remember when we started filming these
meetings people said it was unnecessary
these meetings um and I think that you
know governmental and non-governmental
boards will say that constantly like no
one likes to be filmed but if you're
handling even private money that helps
DHS purchase these products I think it's
uh important that we film and allow the
public to look at these records that's
what I'm here in supportive I can't
speak to the amendment I can't speak to
the question and answer period
representative Schmidt I think you
brought up good questions those should
be answered I think that might be a
little bit too onerous a requirement of
the board but I'm here
in support of Simply audio and video
recording of of the board itself and I
forget who asked it but I was watching
representative dargy I believe that you
did around well why don't we just expand
this to all boards that piece of
legislation is a lot bigger than than
this one piece of legislation
representative ktoa happened to bring
forward the legislation in regards to
this one board I would absolutely
support legislation to have every board
chartered by the state to be filmed
audio and video recorded I mean we're in
the 21st century and uh it's this stuff
is just not that hard to do so that's
all I have to say Madam chair and I I
appreciate the I'll take some questions
I do have to get downstairs ASAP but
representative long has a question if
you could it's appropriate are you aware
of any other private entity that is
subject to these requirements you've
asked that question a few times
representative long and I think you've
so did I hear you correctly that you
would subject all nonprofit boards to
these requirements any board or
organization which was originally
state thank you representative Howard
thank you for taking my question uh so I
know that you mentioned that you'd be
willing to have uh this uh the
recordings of all boards uh be handled
and published online would you be
willing to hold off on this so that we
could work on legislation for next term
to handle that so that every single
board has a requirement to be
recorded this is the committee's bill so
whe whether I'm willing or not as you
know it's not my decision if that's what
the committee decides to do on this
piece of legislation then then we would
move forward with that reality thank you
thank you very much thank you madam
chair other questions thank you
representative wheeler Laura
had she would be happy to answer okay we
will we will receive her written
testimony is there anyone else who
233 all right representative Bixby are
233 that's I thought so all right I have
asked our researcher to look into the
question of why it's an early Bill and
where's the fiscal note uh because I
think we need to know
that I will since no one else wishes to
testify I'll close the hearing and open
the hearing on
vix good morning for the record I'm
representative Peter Bixby from uh Dober
New Hampshire uh straford County
straford District
13 and uh this bill is uh essentially um
um a uh it is uh something that's coming
out of the uh New Hampshire food and
agriculture strategic plan and uh this
is something this is a um something
that's been work been work uh people
have been working on for the last couple
of years in with the goal of uh
significantly
increasing uh New Hampshire ability to
provide food from local farms and local
Fisheries um um and other uh local food
producers and uh as a way of reducing uh
our dependence on food from far away um
and uh so uh I am essentially I am
putting this bill in uh on behalf of uh
Julie Davidson who is a member of that
who has worked on that strateg plan and
is also um a uh uh uh
the board president of the Northeast
organic farmers and garden Farmers
Association of New Hampshire uh I have
my testimony which I uh wrote yesterday
to introduce the bill uh I got a message
from Miss Davidson this morning saying
that she was ill and would not be able
to come in to testify so uh I had
originally expected to testify for about
3 minutes I will uh testify for you do
do my testimony which is about 3 minutes
worth and then I will hit some of the
high points of her testimony uh and then
I would um be happy to answer questions
after that
uh so uh the um the Strategic plan is
something that is uh being done in
cooperation with uh a broad range of uh
food producers and
organizations uh throughout the state
including the uh New Hampshire Food
Alliance and our department of uh food
and food
agriculture agriculture markets and
Foods uh so uh it has broad support
throughout the the um agricultural
Community um and as I mentioned it's uh
the goal of it is to provide a uh have
New Hampshire provide a greater share of
our food so that we can uh encourage
food security and
resilience uh one of
the critical aspects of this plan is
creating stable markets for New
Hampshire Farmers uh the New Hampshire
far Farms of school program does this to
some degree uh but it's a model that
needs to be um create uh expanded in
order to create more impact uh and uh
what this bill would do is create a
study committee that would look into uh
different uh a broader range of ways
that procur procurement uh at the state
and local level uh can provide more
stable Market market and broader markets
for New Hampshire food Growers and um
and
Fishers uh the importance of New
Hampshire agriculture
uh so uh New Hampshire agriculture uh is
important on in several different ways
uh most obviously there's the production
of fresh uh fresh and healthy food for
New Hampshire res residents but beyond
this New Hampshire depends on its
natural
um natural environment to uh for a
substantial portion of our tourist
industry and uh one of the things that
farmers provide essentially at no cost
it to the uh to the state is they
provide critical land stewardship that
supports the natural environment and
preserves the natural environment uh in
addition uh Farms particularly dairy
farms are significant consumers of uh
local Ser goods and services such as
equipment dealers hardware stores and
they contribute significantly
significantly to local economies uh also
serving as as Employers in in local
economies uh so farming is a challenging
and low margin occupation Farms provide
value to the state for which they are
not remunerated uh one way that the
state can help maintain this value that
they provide is using local uh State and
local Pro procurement practices to help
provide uh a broader range of markets
and a more stable range of markets for
our
producers
um
and uh the details of how these procur
procurement plans will would be set up
is something that uh I frankly don't
know how to do yet uh this is why it's a
study committee as opposed to just a
straight bill um so
uh I think that uh What uh in order to
make the in order to make this really
work we need to study this um this
mechanism and uh
I uh I am entirely familiar with the
reluctance on the part of uh the house
to create yet another study committee uh
one of the things that's important in
terms of uh those study study committees
is Staffing and I can I
can um I am fairly sure that my
committee could provide uh two PE two
members of the study committee I think
it would be critical for this committee
to provide one member of that study
committee because uh this committee has
the knowledge of State practices and
administrative practices that um our
committee doesn't is not as well versed
in uh so that is my testimony and I
excuse me before you go on to the policy
of this study committee how many
sessions do you think this study
committee should exist since it has no
expiration date oh one two 10 I I
thought that I had put an expiration
date in it but um if uh if there one
term is okay I my in my expectation was
to have the expiration date on the on on
the committee be uh reporting out
November 1st of 2025 I I didn't
proofread the that's fine I didn't
proofread what came from OS so um that
is cheing that that is a minor amendment
that will need to happen I guess the
other thing is that we have an existing
study committee on state procurement
policy which is a
inactive would you prefer to have this
study combined with that or just repeal
the other one
um I think that uh I don't know what the
other one looks like I don't know
anything about its charge so I think it
probably makes sense to have and and my
my my vision for this study committee is
that it is a you know just for this year
in order to get the me information
necessary to put forward a specific bill
um as opposed to uh sort of the general
practices so I think the other study
committee you can do what you will like
if you want to repeal that as a as an
amendment to this bill that's fine with
me okay thank you very much much I'm I
do so proceeding with the the the
requesters test a moment yes so uh and
this I'm not going to cover she has four
pages I'm you are entirely capable of
reading it I just want to point out a
few of the highlights of it um so uh
this bill directly advances key goals
from the uh food and agricultural
strategic strategic plan then those
goals include uh supporting Farm
viability through expanded Market access
creating Living Way jobs in our local
food system uh building climate
resilience through more sustainable
farming practices and providing food
accessibility for all Granite
Staters
uh another couple of uh on on the
sustainable production end one of the uh
one of the things that the person who
brought it to me was envisioning was
potentially offering tax credits for
retailers who Source from uh sustainable
products uh I'm not sure that that
necessarily uh well so that that might
be one idea of an approach uh and
creating supportive regulations for
public institutions to Source from
sustainable producers which I think is
more in line with the the central idea
of what I perceive the bill to be um and
uh some of the things that go could go
into the study would be evaluating the
economic impacts of the farm farm to
school procurement um and uh looking at
results of that of how that's been U
progressed so far and uh maybe expanding
that um and looking at how this has
worked in some other states uh one one
um thing that look that uh speaks in
favor of it is that uh initial studies
in terms of Farm school programs in New
Hampshire suggests that uh the return uh
uh on that is that a dollar spent on
local food generates about uh a160 in
local economic
activity um and uh so I think that's
let's see sorry
um and uh there is some model
legislation that uh Miss Davidson uh
suggested looking at U I think that
that's something that uh can give us
some ideas I don't think that something
we can really depend on because uh
anything that depends on tax credits
directly to Farmers is probably not
going to be uh as effective as New
Hampshire as it might be in some other
states and that concludes um the my
joint
testimony thank you will you answer
answer some questions sure
representative Pearson I sit on the
state procurement Commission
how how fortunate representative Pearson
how fortunate that is a commission that
takes information it right so the state
procurement commission is more of a come
to us and tell us your story of how your
various group is working is in
procurement how they're requiring things
um we had uh during the beginning of
covid there was a lot of focus on
materials and stuff that was necessary
to process all that and how the state
was was um acquiring things and finding
rotten things in storage areas and that
sort of thing
so if you were to do this if you were to
set this up
specifically
um I would think that logically this
committee would also report to the state
Commission on procurement which handles
the overall broad encompassing
aspect of procurement as as that is what
their purview is they don't set policy
or um it's more of an absorption thing
and then the commission recommends to
the groups that come before us maybe
some ways to help make their life a
little bit easier but that that's what
that's what we
do uh so I think that um if I would I
would be happy to have an amendment to
the bill that said that added uh your
commission to uh the report to where it
reports to and I think that your
commission also could be uh a very um
useful source of information in order to
um to to figure out how best to meet the
goals of this
bill representative leam thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
bringing this bill um I'm not sure if
you're aware but there seems to be
almost an exploding demand for good food
especially good food raised around us in
Dairy we're pretty lucky because we have
jnf Farms that brings in Daily Hall and
other ones where different um providers
um in the state are working together in
order to have a good solid Marketplace
between the community supported
agriculture the Farm Stand and other
processes um I'm curious that with the
burgeoning demand for this local good
food if um if this might actually be
something that that the the demands of
consumers are almost catching up to the
need for sustainable production and if
the Northeast organic farming
Association of New Hampshire is looking
at how to better seed um these
interactions between the farmers and the
other food producers with the people who
are desperately searching for this good
food in their neighborhoods right so um
this is uh this is a yes and uh so one
of the thing so uh the the Strategic
plan also cover is um spends a lot of
time looking at uh how to better uh
connect uh Farmers with uh direct with
direct consumers uh and uh that is uh
and I'm I can't I'm not there are 27
briefs Each of which is about five pages
long and then there's an overriding you
know plan and that's going to be
published in March uh but so that so
this bill is not um trying to supersede
that but one of the things that um so
one of the things about uh farmers
markets and csas is that there's often a
certain amount of fluctuation in demand
uh from that uh makes it difficult for
uh Farmers to necessarily predict uh
what they're going to be producing what
they need to produce um in any given
month and you they certainly have the
ability to um to design to to uh use
their records and use uh exper you
broader experience in order to make some
guesses but one of the things that a
proc procurement program does is it
creates a very steady clear demand and
that is uh provides an easy base to um
to work from and then the farmers
markets and uh uh and csas and whatnot
beyond that would be in addition to what
they have is that steady demand follow
up uh followup um it's my understanding
that CSA is the community supported
agriculture everybody pays the amount of
money ahead of time and agrees that over
the 10 or 13 week growing session
they're going to show up and get that
bush of food no matter if it's full of
zucchini or it's just corn that week in
order to have that consistency and
that's specifically the goal of that it
yes uh consider so csas are a more are a
more steady Source than farmers market
sales but the but uh in order to uh New
Hampshire Farmers uh New Hampshire has
the highest proportion of direct sales
in agriculture of any state and this may
seem like a great thing because you know
here we are at the top but what that one
of the things that means is that uh we
don't our Farmers depend Less on
wholesaling they depend Less on steady
contracts they depend on uh more on
direct sales which tend to fluctuate
more csas are one way to moderate that
uh a proc a procure procurement program
like this is yet is another way to to um
to to help with that and our farmers are
struggling because the cost of
production in the Northeast is higher
than the cost of production in some
other states so uh anything that we can
do to help our Farmers so that they can
continue to be storage of the land is
really important thank you okay other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you right does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill
156 well obviously
not I guess you're you caught up a
little bit yes thank you I appreciate it
um close the public hearing
representative Pearson if you could work
you could tell me where the in statute
that procurement commission you're
you're on is located I'm going to work
on a technical amendment to oh
Lord so this is one of the wonderful
aspects of the speaker's office being
inundated with the hundreds of
commissions and boards that they have to
put people on um and that's how I got on
it I understand I didn't representative
Maguire I'm also on that committee and I
can give you the RSA number please do
okay it's called the advisory committee
on state procurement and it's RSA
2-i colon
14-d and that at according to a report I
got from the speaker's office it hasn't
met in a while is that correct that's
correct corre yeah met um oh Lord it not
it didn't even meet last session it
didn't meet in the last three years and
I recommended just just for full
disclosure I recommended that the
speaker's office um consider either
using it or eliminating it because
there's no sense in having commission if
you're not going to use it yeah we we
met last right right as Co emerged and
then things kind of went haywire okay
thank you all right I will work on an
amendment to House Bill
156 and we'll see and I will report that
it is not actually that house bill 233
is not actually an early bill and it
does not have a fiscal note
so it may have started as one but it
didn't come out of the process with it
can
for
e
uh seeing that it's just after 11:15 I
will open the hearing on House Bill 278
and call the prime sponsor
gerana thank you madam chair honorable
members my name for the record is Nick
tra I am representing chesher 15 which
is Chesterfield Hinsdale Keen Wards 1
and 35 sui Walpole and
westerland the purpose of HB 278 is to
save New Hampshire taxpayers money by
assuring that state purchasing decisions
are made with an eye toward long-term
costs I want to begin by explaining how
carbon pricing works and why we need to
prepare for the effects of international
carbon pricing models in our state
purchasing
decisions carbon pricing is a
market-based alternative to State
imposed caps by placing a price on
carbon emissions carbon carbon pricing
provides incentives for producers to
develop cleaner low carbon
Alternatives the pricing models that are
being implemented around the world are
based on carbon emission goals
established by the International Panel
on climate change to hold Global Climate
rise to 1 and a half degrees above
pre-industrial levels and to reach net
zero emissions by
2050 the ipcc's goals have been adopted
by the international Chamber of Commerce
as a basis for its policy initiatives uh
in the the uh testimony that I emailed
everybody I included a couple of
hyperlinks to uh the site that contain
this
information I want to make uh my
testimony as clear as I can HB 278 is
not a debate about global warming
wherever one stands on the causes of
undeniable climate change we are
experiencing this bill is about how
State purchasing decisions are made in a
changing energy Market countries around
the world including our largest trading
partners are adopting carbon pricing
programs Canada Mexico China and most
European countries have or are in the
process of adopting and implementing
carbon
pricing these programs will increase the
cost of carbon intensive production in
their domestic markets and globally
private companies who conduct business
internationally are preparing for this
shift in global markets by implementing
internal carbon pricing
models HB 278 aims to have the State of
New Hampshire follow the lead of these
businesses and take steps to assure the
most efficient and responsible use of
taxpayers money by factoring carbon
pricing into State purchasing decisions
this is where the proxy carbon pricing
model comes in it's a proxy model
because we do not have a carbon pricing
model uh in place in the United States
however the growth of such models Global
globally will inevitably affect our
Market this is what private business
businesses have already figured out and
begun to act upon the price of carbon
intensive products will continue to rise
we can make the best decisions about how
to use taxpayer money by anticipating
these Rising costs and factoring them
into purchasing decisions for example
when the state builds new facilities or
renovates HVAC systems in existing
facilities we can use a proit proxy
carbon pricing model articulated in the
bill to compare Heating and Cooling in
systems to see which will be most cost
effective over the lifetime of the
system lower carbon emitting systems May
cost more upfront but be considerably
more more cost effective in the long
term I want to be clear HB 278 does not
require the department of administrative
services to make purchasing decisions
based on carbon emissions that is not
the standard used in the bill if a lower
carbon option is not more cost efficient
it would not be
chosen I have been in contact with
commissioner Arling housee and with Gary
lunetta from Das and they have confirmed
that the department can implement the
policy in their evaluation of State
purchasing
decisions the fiscal note which is
attached to the bill was added prior to
my discussions with Das I do not know if
uh that information has changed in light
of our discussions but I have been
assured that the evaluation described in
the bill can be performed by the
department I understand that there will
be a temptation to make a discussion of
this bill about global climate change I
hope and trust that we can remain
focused on the question of how we can
best serve our constituents by making
sound decisions about how to use their
tax dollars in a changing Global energy
Market I know that my colleagues on this
committee on both sides of the aisle
share that commitment thank you for your
time and consideration and I'm very
happy to take any questions um thank you
for that testimony U my first question
would be when you spoke with the
Department of administrative Services
how many full-time employees did they
say this would take because we all know
labor is not
free thank you for the question when I
spoke with Mr lunetta last Friday he
didn't uh he didn't give me a number of
people who would would work on this what
he said was they understand what is
being asked for and if the bill were to
be passed into law they could do
it so uh as a followup they would not
require additional positions in order to
do this I can't say that they wouldn't
he did not say that they would that's
all I can tell you thank you that's
helpful there questions representative
gr so I'm
having
trouble well it's not trouble but I'd
like to have more um an example M okay
so it just and I know that the numbers
are um
would be estimates or even made up right
so could you give let's just say you
have
um
the you want to replace a furnace in one
of the buildings right could you walk us
through what carbon pricing would look
like and how at the end it could be used
to
make well no never mind because we're
not we're just studying it so so let's
just say what would the results be what
would what would at the end of the day
what would you have in this spreadsheet
yes thank you very much for that
question uh excellent question right so
if you're looking at as any of us would
do right if we're going to heat our our
homes right and and obviously if we're
talking about state buildings are much
larger than our homes or at least mine
uh but you would do a cost comparison
right thinking about what it would cost
you to operate something over the long
term and if if you're going with uh an
oil furnace for example you would take
into account as best you could not only
installation costs but if you could
project the average price of oil out
over that lifetime of the product right
so that gives you a a guess you could
have some you could have a heat pump as
an alternative for example right and
again look at installation costs look at
the average cost to operate a heat pump
thermal heat pump over the course of of
that time right you would come to a
decision one of those is going to be
more cost effective one might be more
expensive upfront more cost effective in
the long run so similarly what what the
uh Department of administrative Services
would do is to take a look at the
different options are that are out there
and the way that the proxy carbon
pricing Works in is it's not just the
cost of installation and it's not just
the cost of say oil it also the formula
that is uh provided in the bill which is
based on the Canadian model would also
be factor in factored in and what that
does is it factors in a cost an
increasing cost of carbon over the years
and over decades right so that would be
added to the estimate that you would do
so I hope that helps you would look at
different Alternatives and uh one of the
the data points you would use to
consider is how much carbon does it
consume and what does the carbon market
look like over 10 or 20 years and that
would help you decide what the total
cost of operation that system is as
opposed to a system that uses less
carbon or no
follow so just so that I understand I'm
going to do it on a very different I'm
going to heat my house with an oil
furnace I'm going to consider how much
it cost to put that oil furnace in and
how much it cost to buy the furnace and
then I'm going to calculate for the next
let's say the furnace life is 10 years
just for Simplicity I'm going to
calculate how much oil I'm going to need
to buy to heat my house for the next 10
years based on I'm going to base on what
I've done before right so at the end I'm
going to say
that 20 I I'm going to spend $20,000 on
the furnace putting it in and buying oil
for 10
years and then I'm going to look at a
different thing I'm going to look at um
same system hot floor chock water but
I'm going to use solar panels okay I'm
going to going to cost out how much it
cost to put the solar panels in I'm
going to cost how much it run it takes
to run those solar panels and I'm going
to say that at the end of the year it
cost me $20,000 to install the solar
panels and everything else so I would
think that because we're using a solar
panel the carbon cost is higher for the
coal for the oil because oil is a carbon
derivative whereas the solar panel is
using the sun is that pretty much where
we are yes okay so in those two oh so
cases that's obvious because we can say
that oil is carbon derived and sun is
not so let's say we're looking at oil
versus
propane right we would determine the
cost of those two systems and then we
would determine they were the same let's
say there's $20,000 a
piece there would be a carbon proxy fee
added to that for analysis
purposes because one of these two
sources is more carbon dependent than
the
other yes exactly you explained it very
well and and we do have a a formula here
that goes for example for for natural
gas which is a little bit different U
because of of the chemical kind of
makeup of the fuel but uh yes that is
correct and and so the department would
kind of play both of those scenarios out
over the course of the lifetime of that
system determine that one of them would
be more cost effective and and also I I
would add that one of the other features
uh obviously that the uh the Das would
have to consider again is I referred to
the size of of the buildings obviously
they're dealing with you and I might be
able to use solar panels effectively to
to provide energy for our homes you're
talking about much much larger
structures obviously it's much less
efficient to use something like solar
panels right so even though and that's
where I wanted to point out this the the
M the measure that Dees would be using
is not carbon emissions it's the price
right so when they look at it and they
say there's no way to efficiently heat a
government building using solar
panels it it is ultimately more cost
efficient because of the square footage
to to heat with oil or gas or whatever
then that is is ultimately what you
would
choose thank you person Leon thank you
madam chair uh listening to this and
hearing this you're talking about
market-based carbon pricing but in this
it's not market-based you have an
inflation adjusted um adjustment what
kind of confidence do you have that $325
per ton in 2050 would be an appropriate
price thank you and that's an excellent
question and uh I'm not an economist so
I know that I'm not going to be able to
give you the best answer to that
question the answer that I have is that
this is designed to fit into the
emerging International Market on pricing
so that what that will be uh I I don't
think even economists but that's just a
guess would be able to tell you that
with great confidence they'd be able to
predict what that price is going to be
in 2050 but the uh the method that is
described in the bill as I said is meant
to have this model be in the ballpark of
our major trading partners assuming that
whatever price it is will be in that
same ballpark with the other
industrialized countries that are our
major trading
partners thank you representative ree
thank you madam chair um I'm not
understanding some of the text on the
fill and the pricing and I'm hoping that
you can explain it to me because you it
says here that beginning in January 2026
the commissioner she'll use axy carbon
price of $85 per ton and then that
increases $10 per ton um up until 2050
which representative Leon shared and
then it says prices shall be inflation
adjusted from a 2010 valuation so are
are the prices being set by this or or
are they being adjusted and why 2010 I'm
sorry I'm just
confused yeah thank you very much for
that question that marker is one that is
established in other carbon pricing
systems as a baseline so it's meant to
provide again to make this a model which
is comparable to the models that exist
in other countries European models and
and and Canada the Canadian model in
particular is the one that was used to
create the structure in this bill so
it's providing the same Baseline as
exists in other
um other systems I honestly could not
tell you why 2010 was chosen um but so
it is right it is adjusted as you said
uh on an annual basis and then there is
an inflation inflation adjustment as
well followup thank you so that it's the
$10 per year that would be infl
inflation adjusted is what you're you're
saying the $10 increase is what would be
a yes my understanding uh is that the
the annual adjustment right the increase
is what's inflation adjusted thank you
that thank you for that clarifying
question that was very important than
you representative
long I guess I don't understand the
state procurement process very well
because it it seems to me like
calculating the long-term costs of a
purchase that you're making uh would be
a standard business practice and I say
that as a small business owner uh and so
it's I guess what are they doing now
that there would be any suggestion that
they would need more staff to carry this
out thank you for that question I think
it's a very reasonable question and I
also uh you know an ear member earlier
had asked the question about staff and
the fact is I just don't have an answer
for that when I spoke to Mr lunetta he
did not say that more staff would be
required so I cannot speak to the
question whether more staff would be
required to do this work they simply
said they understood what the bill is is
it I believe if I I could it it requires
the procurement Department to calculate
an adjustment factor for any of these
assorted building cost transportation
and new new construction which would
incorporate instead of the current
prices and long-term cost it would put
in a fudge factor to account for for
carbon so it would complicate the
procurement process but it would be at a
ju when choosing a a
system representative sers thank you
madam chair um I have a few questions
but I'll start with one why don't we
just have a national model instead of a
thank you very much for the question
there has been some momentum in Congress
in in recent years uh congresswoman
kuster has come out in favor of a
national carbon uh pricing model uh
there just has not been will within
Congress as with many things to to do it
so there there are a certain number of
representatives in Congress who have
been advocating for this but as I said
like many other things uh it simply has
represent followup yes please thank you
madam chair
um I'm just uh we we've never had this
before correct so this is
new and why do we need it now I mean I'm
I'm over 60 years old I'm never heard of
cin credits until the last few years of
course but why do we need this now
thank you that's an excellent question
uh while I am a historian so I can say a
little bit about the history I'm not a
historian of energy policy but actually
the idea of a carbon pricing model goes
back to to the 1980s and and some
members of the Reagan Administration
actually uh who first forwarded the idea
as an alternative to some proposals that
were being put forward in the 80s uh
around simply capping carbon emissions
right then if you remember in the late '
90s ear early 2000s there was a
discussion about cap and trade um so the
discussion actually is not new at a
national level and and the first people
to begin to articulate a model like this
as a as a market-based alternative to
State imposed uh schemes goes back to
the 1980s the reason why there's more
discussion of it now is because our
major trading partners in particular
Canada Mexico China and most of the
European States who are major trading
partners are implementing the policies
within the past few years and that is
what is shaping the global energy Market
uh and companies that are doing business
internationally right now are having to
figure out how to account in their own
business practices for the change in the
market so it has become more pressing in
recent years because it's been adopted
in other countries but the idea goes
1980s thank followup yeah thank you and
just to make sure I'm trying to be clear
on this too is so if I'm a builder and
I'm building a new 3,000 ft house and
I'm sure dep depending on what type of
heating Source I put in how much would
that cost how much more will that cost
to that house add to that house U thank
you and I think it's important to to
clarify any this is strictly for for
State purchasing decision so it will not
in any way shape or form
effect anything beyond that right so
work that you do on your home I would
say those costs are are going to go up
because carbon is going to go up but
that's the market independent of this
this is strictly uh for State purchasing
decisions and does not apply to any
private
parties thank you representative JG
thank you madam chair um what do exactly
do you mean by um transportation cost is
just Transportation cost relative to uh
building buildings or Transportation
cost in general for moving things around
thank you very much for that question it
would be the ladder so if you're
thinking about the fleet of automobiles
for example that the state has right and
it's technological developments around
electric vehicles or hybrid vehicles Etc
uh as we replace vehicles uh for various
purposes uh for the state this kind of
calculation would be done to determine
are certain kinds of vehicles more cost
effective I mean we do that anyway I
assume using various factors right which
cars are we going to buy uh in this case
it would apply for example to
state okay other other questions not
seeing any thank you representative
thank you very
that
you should turn your microphone on
please no if blue or red was
on thank you madam chair and Edna
committee members um I'm John Gage from
Windam I support this bill
um I'm the volunteer New Hampshire State
coordinator with a group called citizens
climate Lobby um I've been the state
coordinator for six years and we working
to create political will to enable
Congress to pass
bipartisan carbon fee and dividend
legislation um The Economist statement
describes the policy that we are uh
proposing the the federal government to
it is a steadily Rising carbon fee on
fossil fuel producers and importers all
the money is rebated back to households
as an equal per capita dividend each
month and a border adjustment so we can
charge our price on imports from free
polluting countries the reason that that
Mr Gage would be a national policy
correct that would be a national policy
we're not proposing to do that in New
Hampshire thank you um the reason you do
it at the national level is because of
trade because you can if you have a
price on pollution in your own economy
you can charge at the border a carbon
import tariff and in fact the treasury
secretary that was just
um um Trump had nominated and it was
just uh confirmed by
a strong majority in the Senate um has
is very interested in using a border
import carbon tariff um because we can
charge dirtier polluting countries for
their pollution um at the border so that
that will raise the cost of goods from
China and India and Russia um so but
we're not here to talk about what I do
at the federal level but by my
volunteering with this group group I
have developed some insights about
what's going on in the world that I like
to share with you I didn't save a copy
so I'm not going to be able to tell the
page numbers
um there's a graph of carbon prices that
the ipcc has set to meet the Paris
targets um it's the first large graph in
yeah it's on the back of the first page
minimum carbon price required to hold
global warming to 1 and a half degrees
versus the actual price of just a small
sample of countries that are pricing
carbon or not the US EU and Canada the
gry line comes from an ipcc report um
called the special report on global
warming of 1.5 which specifies The
Economist estimate for a price range
that's necessary to meet the target so
the gry line is the bottom of the price
range the top of the price range is much
higher um because it depends on what
other complimentary policies are put
into place in order to meet the
pollution reduction targets so what we
did for this bill was we just said
okay the every country in the world
committed to holding warming to 1 and a
half degrees and many of them are
listening to economists and following
the recommended price path for
carbon we're going to somewhere higher
Switzerland is actually much higher than
the minimum but the EU and Canada are
pretty much on track on that minimum
price range the reason that the us is
going to start carrying is they are
going to charge us uh a free polluting
country uh for our pollution when we
export goods into those markets so that
it's called the
carbon border adjustment mechanism and
there's different ways of doing it but
the E the acronym is cbam and it's just
a lot easier to say so a cbam is an
import tariff on carbon emissions so the
EU cbam starts next year we us exporters
uh that are exporting Goods into the U
Market will have to start paying um the
EU carbon price um at the border so that
our goods sold in that economy reflect
the same cost on pollution that Goods
produced in the EU automatically
reflect um so when China learned that
the EU was going to do this China does
price carbon in their industrial sector
but not in their steel production um
they started looking into moving steel
production into their carbon Market
because carbon pricing is the most
cost-effective way to reduce carbon
pollution um other countries are
following the EU the UK starts its cbam
in 2020
2027 um Japan starts its cbam in
2028 okay so let's take a look at this
world graph picture this shows about a
quarter of the fossil fuels sold in the
world are already under some carbon
price and the US is actually the only
developed country which does not price
carbon um there's a graph
showing uh figure five on the last page
at the bottom the expansion of carbon
pricing around the world and the percent
of uh carbon emissions that are being
priced um so it started in 1990 very
small percentage but today it's nearly
25% and prices are rising as we saw from
that ipcc Gray Line going up these
countries are not just pricing carbon
but their prices are rising there's
there's graphs showing um select
countries prices rising so I think the
picture I want to paint in your mind is
that carbon pricing is spreading around
the world prices are rising and C bams
are coming now businesses in the US are
anticipating a federal carbon price by
using proxy carbon
pricing um both to reduce their
emissions but also uh as a risk
management um
tactic um people in you
know the at the federal level it's kind
of accepted that we have to praise
carbon it's also accepted that it's
going to be very difficult for the US to
price carbon so what I do as a volunteer
is I work to educate people about good
policies if you return the money back to
people we all come out ahead we need to
do it um but businesses are going to be
more and more forc pushing the
government to do
it so what you know why don't we do this
at the federal level not the state level
yes exactly we need to price carbon at
the federal level so why are we bother
bothering talking about it at the state
level because by anticipating a future
carbon price at the federal level we can
save New Hampshire taxpayer
dollars if we're going to buy a heating
system for a new State Building we have
a choice um and if if you look at the
cost of a heat pump versus a gas boiler
um and then the life cycle cost of
operating the thing over the 20 or 30
years that the equipment will be there
so this bill doesn't change your initial
cost estimate of how much it costs to do
a heat pump versus a gas boiler it's
just the price but this carbon price gap
which we anticipate coming at us from
above in the future is what we want to
add into the total life cycle cost of
each of the options so for a heat pump
there is no additional cost uh from a
carbon price um for a gas boiler there's
going to be a certain additional price
for the fuel each
year that I feel the state should
anticipate because it's highly likely uh
that it will happen at some point in the
next 10 years or less and so we're I'm
just trying to save people New Hampshire
taxpayers money
by sharing the Insight that I've learned
as a volunteer working at the federal
level to price carbon um about what's
happening around the world uh and even
in Congress
um Congress came very close to pricing
carbon two years ago um it was one vote
shy of including a carbon fee and
dividend in the inflation reduction act
that passed in
20122 came very close um and political
will is growing we're we're going to
keep working on this until it happens so
so I had a couple answers for questions
uh yeah adjusted FL for inflation so
$100
today um is not equal to $100 in 2010 so
all of the prices that are listed here
are $210 so even the starting price
$85 that would be $85 in 2010 so we'd
have to adjust it for inflation to to
know what the real start prices and then
so the the whole thing is adjusted for
inflation um as far as staff
considerations I can't imagine anybody
this is just adding one more light item
in calculations that already been done
just adding in a dollar amount which is
very easy to calculate for the price of
gas diesel or gasoline um over the over
you know they know when they buy a
vehicle about how much gas it's going to
burn in its life cycle so you just add
extra cost in
um why now because the European cbam is
starting next year uh so this has been
developing for you know 10 years um but
we're really seeing things happening in
the US was trying to get around the EU
cbam um for the last couple years and
they have been unable to do it we're
going to our exporters are going to
start paying this money next year so we
have confidence that you know this is
really a real thing um just to give you
an idea for an example $10 per ton of
CO2 adds about 10 cents in a gallon of
gas so we're anticipating you know gas
will will add 85 cents per gallon of gas
when it starts and then we'll add 10
cents more per gallon of gas um each
year after that so they just have to add
a little extra cost in the total life
cycle cost of a gasoline car
Option electric vehicle there's no
additional cost um for for carbon
pricing so it just tips the balance
toward heat pumps and electric vehicles
um you know not severely um but there's
a reason that we're doing this um to
anticipate a future carbon price and
hundreds of countries hundreds of us
businesses and um states and cities are
doing it on the first page followed
following and going on to the second
page um there's a list of
um for example the Minnesota pu is using
proxy carbon pricing when it is deciding
on energy
projects and and others are doing the
same thing so this is a thing that other
states are doing uh to anticipate a
future carbon price so that they don't
get stuck with stranded assets and waste
taxpayer dollars thank you did you
representative Leon um thank you madam
chair and thank you Mr Gage um I think
you might be uniquely suited to answer
this question um sorry I'm going to give
you sort of a two-part one is this
really why my mom's paying a dollar more
in gas in California than we are here
but the one that you're most suited for
is um could you tell us what the actual
price on January 1st 2026 for this $85 a
ton would be based on this 2010
valuation
okay so um I don't I don't pretend to
understand California's energy markets
um they do have a cap and trade system
in California but as the last I heard it
was something like $35 per ton of CO2 so
that would be adding it's actually n
cents per gallon but 10 cents is 10
cents per for each $10 is easier to
calculate so I'd as I'd guess 35 cents
more per gallon because of the carbon
price but some reason regions actually
exclude gasoline from their carbon
Market um which um I'm I'm pretty sure
California the cap in trade doesn't
cover gasoline I I think that's just for
electricity generation but I'm I'm not
not totally
sure and you didn't have the price for
the $85 today based on those $20 because
I thought you said it was simple it is
simple but you need some information in
front of you to make the calculation all
you need to know is how much inflation
was there between 2010 and today so
let's say it was 100% uh inflation I
know it wasn't but it's so anyway the
answer is you don't know right now yes
thank you it would be easy to figure out
if I knew the inflation number uh thank
you for taking my question so looking at
the map that you provided it's a little
bit difficult to read it I know that it
says Massachusetts is one of the states
that has uh adopted a similar Poli polic
it looks like Maine as well could you
just kind of clarify what surrounding
states in New England uh have adopted
similar
policies sure um yeah we we have a
carbon price here actually um the
northeast states um are uh involved in
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
regie and this is a CPP and trade system
that was set up a little more than 10
years ago to put a price on carbon
emissions from electricity generators
so uh I don't know if we have the Reggie
price in one of these charts it depends
on the year uh yeah it does so the
Reggie shows up on
um a page that has two graphs on it it's
on the bottom um regie has a very small
carbon price for for a long time it was
about $5 per ton of CO2 uh it crept up
close to $15 per ton last time I looked
uh last year um so but that's just for
power generators and um so each state
gets to decide what to do with that
money New Hampshire returns most of it
in the form of a rebate in the
electricity bill um a dollar of per ton
uh is actually used to fund some Energy
offers the questions representative
long do you have any data on what our
total energy usage as a state government
is right now and what it's projected to
be in the
future um I can take some guesses I
haven't been paying a lot of attention
I've heard $6 billion dollar a year is
spent on energy in New Hampshire and
something like four and a half billion
of that is on fossil fuel energy um you
know if you look at our economy that
billions of dollars going to um fossil
fuel producing but that's the state not
the state government oh sorry um you I
didn't catch that part no I do not um
but you know every vehicle so I just did
this in my personal life my furnace died
in April I needed to replace the heating
machine in my building uh and my car
died and I need to to get to replace it
I did all the numbers and it was um
because I have forced hot water I ended
up buying an oil furnace um but also
investing energy efficiency um for
transportation um I bought an EV um
because the the break even um saving
money um part is just it was like four
or five years out it I I paid more for
the vehicle up front but I will save
money um per mile um you know over the
life cycle of the
car so this you know the state will save
money I can't tell you how much but if
they do this and then carbon pricing
happens at the federal level we'll save
significant money um if it doesn't
happen then we will just be a little
cleaner um than we would have been but
we will generally often save money
anyway for some of these
things thank you
followup yeah so I guess if I'm
understanding both this bill and current
policy correctly there one way they both
differ from what I would consider
standard business practice is
that you know if I were dealing with
conditions of uncertainty uh as there is
with the possibility of carbon
pricing uh you know I wouldn't really
consider the cost straight yes or no I'd
try to get a probability estimate and a
worst case scenario
estimate um does it make sense to do
something like that uh instead of just a
straight up you know this is the cost
estimate yeah the bill has two
um outcomes one is it determines the
decision that's made and the state does
the purchase based on this another is
that the decision is reported
so they report on you know why they made
the decision to to go with something if
their mind was changed uh because of
this carbon price it would be reported
so uh you could just do the reporting
side um I don't think the paperwork to
do this is is very intensive it would be
just one more line item in the in the
total life cycle cost of these things
the downside of just doing this on paper
is it's like having a good idea about a
stock and not buying it but tracking it
for the next two years and then if it's
gone up times 10 two years from now um
all you know is that you could have
saved your you could have made some
money you didn't actually make the money
so I don't know that it would really
help to just do the paperwork if we're
not going to make the decisions based on
it but you're right risk management is
why companies do this they maybe you
know so this is a very minimum necessary
price to meet our climate goals uh I
suspect at some point the price will go
have to go well above the Gray Line uh
so this is already a pretty conservative
price to be making your decisions on
followup I just want to clarify my
question because I wasn't
suggesting just doing the paperwork to
you have the information available what
I was suggesting is something more like
you know if I thought there was a 5050
chance of a carbon pricing being adopted
and it would be $150 a ton then instead
of saying the cost of this is zero
because it doesn't exist yet or it's 150
because I think that's what it's going
to be then from a business perspective
what I would do is I would estimate it
at $75 a ton but then also you know
consider the 150 as a worst case
scenario um but I I would most likely
make my purchasing decision using that
$75 a ton
number uh because that seems like the
overall best likely to produce the most
value for that purchasing decision so
does it make sense to do something like
that for State
procurement that's a good question I
think you'd probably want to talk to a
state Economist or something to figure
out I'm not a business person I was in
computer software engineering for 30
years and now I'm learning about energy
policy but I know Exxon runs two sets of
books and I think a lot of companies do
this also one with a proxy carbon price
and one was prices as they are I don't
know if when they make decisions where
in the spectrum they choose to go they
could go halfway in between they could
think that carbon pricing is less likely
now um so maybe they down they they go
closer to just actual prices thank you
gentlemen but I don't really think we
should speculate on what organizations
we know very little about are actually
doing I don't see anybody here from the
state procurement office to talk about
what they actually do regarding Future
Energy prices and we would need to know
that to consider offering them
advice are there any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you there's nobody else here to testify
so I'm going to close the public
pm.
e
Fred could you uh remind John that we're
will thank you madam chair and esteemed
members of the committee my name is uh
representative Matt Wilhelm I represent
Manchester Ward one in the general court
and uh it's great to be with you here in
Edna I'm introducing House Bill 516 FN
uh which would establish a new full-time
position at volunteer New Hampshire uh
specifically to look at post uh service
Pathways for americor Lums and turn
peace score volunteers um back in in
just a little bit of background and
context would you repeat that repeat
that your goal please sure it it would
establish a position to support uh Post
Service
Pathways and it's really about
connecting uh alumni of Civilian
national service programs so americore
and Peace Corp
uh to an affordable degree or credential
in New Hampshire uh and a meaningful
career so volunteer New Hampshire is a
quasi government agency it's uh it was
established uh back in the
1990s uh there's a state Service
Commission in every state um it receives
no State
funding uh and really supports the
infrastructure
of uh civilian national service programs
like americore uh as well as uh just
community-based volunteering across the
state um we are a state that is uh
operated our presence here in this room
uh we all know how important
volunteerism is in the state of New
Hampshire and uh volunteer New Hampshire
provides a catalyst uh and support for
uh volunteer organizations mostly uh
nonprofit and public sector
organizations that are leveraging uh
volunteer power to make a difference in
the
community so back in
2020 I guess it was 2019 uh there was a
commission to study career Pathways from
full-time service year programs to
postsecondary education and employment
in New Hampshire uh and I can provide
the committee with uh a copy of the
final report and
recommendations uh but really the the
focus was how do we attract and retain
uh more young people who are
community-minded and service driven who
have a track record of that uh how do we
keep them here so that they are
contributing members uh of our Workforce
moving forward um there were several
recommendations that were in the final
report including uh beefing up americore
schools of service which matches uh the
education award that americore alumni
received when they
finish their their full-time year of
service uh which is equal to about the
pel grants so it's it's it's
approximately six or $7,000 a year um
institutions of higher ed in the state
could match uh that $7,000 so it becomes
$144,000 um which makes it much more
appealing for a young person to say yes
I want to stay in New Hampshire uh to to
pursue my future career goals um there's
also a program called
um uh called employers for national
service which is an opt-in program uh no
cash involved at all but uh basically
public private and nonprofit employers
uh opt in and say we really value uh the
type of experience that someone who has
done one of these service
programs um and we want to make sure
that we are prioritizing them uh when
they are applying for a job and so these
are just two examples of the types of
national programs that are out there uh
that don't have a large presence here in
the state of New Hampshire and the the
purpose of the bill uh is to uh create a
new position at volunteer New Hampshire
uh that can work on these types of
initiatives uh to build out uh that post
service
um Post Service infrastructure within
the state uh so that more institutions
of higher ed are taking advantage of the
human capital that exists in these
alumni uh as well as employers uh and so
I think the fiscal note uh says that in
FYI 26 uh it' be approximately $75,000
all in um which sounds about right to me
and uh excited to take your
questions thank you I have a question
approximately how many americore and
peace cor alumni do we have at any given
time or come off the program any year
yeah so on a given year um the most
recent stats I have I think go back
three years uh and it was
365 uh in one year or three years in one
year in one year okay so I can get some
updated numbers on that um I'll send
that over when I I follow up with the
committee okay representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh what's the
situation n Nationwide
representative uh is this a
common uh outcome that the states
recognize the value that these people
have achieved in assisting the nation's
Mission and and so forth in in uh other
countries or here in the United States
and they recognize that there's a lot of
potential in these people for public
service and they are supporting it in
it's the same way we're attempting to do
here or is this a unique I'm sure it's
not a unique thing but what is the
situation Nationwide in this regard yeah
thanks for the question representative
the I think each state is looking at
this differently and I think some some
states are uh recognize the power and
potential of connecting their national
service alumni with uh Post Service
Pathways uh more than others um there
are a handful of models that we can
point to from other States uh some you
know create a a position that will help
to uh oversee and support uh this type
of work uh and then there are other uh
states that have just been doing it
organically where institutions of higher
ed say this is the exact type of young
person that we want on our campus we're
raising our hand right now we're saying
we want to match that education award um
because our campus has a strong stronger
Civic life uh as a result of those folks
pursuing their their secondary degre so
uh could you give us is there anything
in writing that we can look at to see
whether we're doing the most to exploit
the opportunity of these young people's
uh skills and dedication you bet I will
uh follow up with some examples as well
as uh some private studies that have
been done uh that both interview uh
colleges and universities as well as
employers who are saying the hard skills
and the soft skills that they
uh develop over the course of their
service experience uh are really valued
thank you very
much
SL uh representative hel wilham uh to
whom does this person report how does he
where does he fit into the world so I
imagine that the uh position would
report to the executive director of
volunteer New Hampshire which uh is
overseen by a a governor appointed um
Commission
yes representative Leon um thank you
madam chairman and thank you for
bringing this bill to us my question is
you said that this was a federally
funded program would this be the first
um expenditure of State funds on
volunteer NH or are there already State
funds going to it my understanding is
that aside from the ink kind um office
space that they get as part of the State
Office Park uh there are no State funds
that go to volunteer New Hampshire at
this
time but this person would obviously L
be a state
employee so technically they would be a
employee of volunteer New Hampshire
which is a separate 501c3 nonprofit
organization so which is why I describ
them as a quasi governmental agency so
these State service commissions uh are
set up differently in different states
um at one point this lived in the
governor's office the state Service
Commission volunteer New Hampshire um
it's currently administratively attached
Das correct
so you actually may have a better answer
to that question than I do
okay represent L uh thank you Madame
chair uh do you know if there are other
situations where we directly fund
employees at nonprofits as opposed to
the sort of bulk um payment that we have
to some of the nonprofits that then go
ahead and hire those
employees uh I am not aware I think that
I think the way volunteer New Hampshire
is set up is is pretty unique within the
state of New Hampshire
um so I actually look forward to
learning more about how exactly it would
be funded and whether they would
technically be a state employee or if
they'd be an employee of the 501c3
nonprofit well that makes a significant
benefits all right representative
sellers thank you madam chair I'm trying
to find out does this organization uh
volunteer New Hampshire do they not work
with this uh support group Post Service
college right
now so right now uh it's really up to
employers uh you know whether it's a
private sector or nonprofit or even the
you know the state of New Hampshire
could decide that they want to be part
of employers for national service they
would have to discover the program on
their own and then opt in uh and so this
is really an effort based on the
commission's report back in
2020 uh to build build in uh someone who
can really coordinate those efforts uh
so that we can recruit additional
employers of national service as well as
uh additional schools of service so
right right now it would just be on the
institutions of pyed or the employers to
discover it on their own uh and so this
is really an opportunity to organize and
and and build up that infrastructure in
way other
thank you represent we might ask uh is
is it the request of the uh umbrella
organization or this is uh something
that you and the other sponsors have
come up with so volunteer New Hampshire
uh was part of the commission back in
2020 right uh and they are aware of the
request uh they wanted to be careful not
to say they support it or don't support
it um but they're aware of it and
certainly see the benefits thank you
thank you
okay thank you representative I don't
think there's anyone else to
testify thanks Madam chair I'll follow
all right I think we should go into
executive session since we've got a few
minutes representative scitec do you
no no you okay you don't have a
chance um in that case representative
scitec does not have a motion I'll move
inexpedient to
and I'll just say that this might be a
very nice thing to have but if
we're but it's very very definitely a
nice to have and not a necessary to have
uh I didn't get much of an impression
that they knew why it was
a full-time position to do things that
these other organizations are doing on
their own and
I don't think we should be at trying to
add more state employees in nice to have
functions when the governor's just
imposed a hiring
freeze representative Leon uh thank you
madam chair um I definitely appreciate
the intention to keep people of Don
americ cor and peace Peace Corp here and
do this but I don't think that this has
been fully fleshed out enough in order
to try and make a new position when
we're facing the constraints that we
have today
um there's so many there's so many
things that I can see that can be done
with that $75,000 of budget um that
really would have a direct impact on a
lot of different lives and I just don't
it any other comments questions concerns
representative
scitec this my view this had reasonable
chance but this the economic argument
even though I know that's the job of
Finance we shouldn't ask Finance to be
doing uh what we what we recognize has
to be done and it's it's sound like a
great idea but I'm not sure we can
afford it right or should afford it
reluctantly that's it thank
de I'm of two minds on this but I really
like to see the updated numbers on how
many volunteers are here so um I guess
we're moving forward with it anyway but
um there is a multiplying effect by
having a volunteer manager Who Um can
help to create a stickiness within the
state of New Hampshire so I think that
there's a benefit that far exceeds the
cost in response to that the executive
director
I don't who I believe is paid with
federal funds has the authority to hire
people to
uh um do these to organize programs to
to do that to contact with other
nonprofit
organizations
um and cooperate with any state federal
agency or any private
organization and also to accept gifts
grants and donations from any funds so
my my feeling is that if it's important
which I do think it it it very well
should
be they have the authority to go ahead
and raise money to do so or to connect
other organizations to these National
programs it sounded from what
representative wilham said is that
they're not actually pushing these
National organizations to their partners
and that would be in my opinion the
do representative
sers yeah thank you mam chair I'm just
thinking that it's they're not on what
you were just saying and it's it doesn't
sound like they had even attempted to
start doing this even part-time on their
own yet so I mean if we already had say
you know they're already put in 10 hours
a week and now they really need someone
full-time that's one thing but we they
want to start a whole program which I'm
not sure if they even know will work or
won't anyone else comments
questions the ch's in the right
place
disagree all right no one else has
anything to say motion is inexpedient to
legislate and the clerk can call the
role Vice chairman Lon
yes representative Bailey
yes representative Shan
yes representative sers
yes representative groa she stepped out
oh I'm sorry I didn't see that
representative Schmidt
yes representative Davis
yes representative Dary
yes representative he uh Howard I'm
sorry no worries yes um representative
St re
whoops representative long
no okay and the chair yes
two four six eight 10 to two all right
the motion passes do do does anyone wish
to write a Minority
Report repr re I'd be willing to thank
you okay when yes representative re will
write a minority minority report
therefore it cannot go on consent okay
and it will be on the regular calendar
I'm sorry I I have no objection to
actually going on consent if you don't
want many
know two
two oh
sorry madam chair yes I
have in the sorry new to this in the
absence if you want this to go onto the
consent agenda I have no objection to
that and and passing on writing a
Minority Report I they don't have a
burning passion to write a minority
report for something that's un theast
you please say so I mean we're it's it's
if you want to make your point that's
perfectly represent long do you wish uh
I don't no okay all right so so
representative re is not writing a
Minority
Report does anyone object to consent at
all anyone no okay we will put this on
consent
then hey I even
we've got people here for the for the
1:30 I don't think we've got time for
another
bill we will take we will resume at 1:30
report
e
back uh opening the hearing on House
thank you madam chairwoman members of
the committee uh thank you so much for
having me here today for the record I am
representative Jim majori representing
the beautiful community and the
wonderful residents of Northampton New
Hampshire uh and I'm here today in full
support of House Bill
469 uh I'm not going to speak at length
about this the people behind me are the
real pros um they can answer probably
all of your questions uh but I'm really
here in support because I'm one of the
Selectmen in town and have been for well
18 years now uh so I know how important
it is for our communities to have access
uh for our town managers for our uh Town
administrators to have access direct
access to the funding that directly
affects the residents of our community
um so I think think the addition of a
municipal manager on this board would be
very effective to have that direct input
on the advisory Council excuse me uh to
have that direct input uh that's coming
right from the town to The Advisory
Council I think that is a great addition
and that's what we're talking about
today you probably did some homework
about the history of P dip and and
there's a lot of things that's uh that's
not the discussion we're having right
now it's adding uh it's adding this one
member of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association uh excuse me Municipal
Managers Association and removing one of
the bankers we still have the same
representation there I think this is a
wonderful idea and again I'm happy to
take any question but I'll probably keep
saying the folks behind me can answer
that the folks behind me can answer that
so with that I uh that's about all I
have all right thank you very much sure
represent lean does have a question
thank you madam chair um my question is
you're talking about adding a municipal
manager um is removing one of the
bankers something that's an important
issue to you or were you just trying to
keep the number of people in membership
the same I think number of people in
membership the same thank you yep okay
other
questions all right thank you very much
thank you very
hail good afternoon um and I apologize I
realized I didn't put uh the uh time to
speak and I think that's I trust you'll
be brief and effective Y at the most um
uh Madam chair honorable members of the
house educ uh executive department
administration committee uh for the
record my name is Ryan hail vice
president government relations for the
New Hampshire Bankers Association New
Hampshire Bankers represents 40 member
banks uh which employ roughly 6,000
employees um it's an honor to be here
today um I don't usually uh uh sit in
front of this committee so it's nice get
to see everyone
um we're opposed to uh HB 469 not in its
entirety uh we're not opposed to adding
a member from the municipal Managers
Association but as you can imagine we're
opposed to eliminating one of our seats
right now we have two seats on The
Advisory Board this has been it's been
this way for nearly 30 years and so
we're curious to why there's a change
need for a change uh we feel it's even
more important now to have those voices
considering the house made a policy
decision last year to keep some of the
funds held by this pool in banks in New
Hampshire we feel having these seats
adds and ensures accountability um uh of
the board uh
furthermore excuse me one of our members
that sits on the board is not affiliated
with a bank and is actually a retired
Banker uh with a lot of knowledge about
uh about Banking and uh financing um so
so like I mentioned I keep it short um
in conclusion while we're not impo
opposed to the bill in its entirety we
are opposed to eliminating one of our
seats and I'm happy to take any
you excellent job no questions thank you
that was
Buton turn your
mic you thank
you I will be brief as well uh my name
is Todd selig and I'm testifying in
favor of HB 469 as a member of the
municipal Management Association of New
Hampshire I also serve as the
administrator for the town of Durham in
my role as Town Administrator it qualif
ifies me to be a member of the municipal
Management Association of New Hampshire
membership in mmh is only available to
Municipal Employees who satisfy six
different criteria two that require a
person to Be an Effective control of the
overall administrative function and to
have significant external responsibility
members of the MMA are key decision
makers for cities and towns across the
state we've been following the evolution
of the New Hampshire Public deposit
investment pool for many years the
recent change ders in the oversight of
the pool from the New Hampshire banking
Department to the state treasure have
brought the New Hampshire Public deposit
investment pool in line with similar
pools from throughout the country adding
a member of the MMA to the pool would
represent another good step as part of
the pool's Evolution and progression I'd
be happy to answer any questions you may
have um Mr selig um Mr hail made the
point that there's a bunch of money held
by New Hampshire in New Hampshire bank
so that it's appropriate that New
Hampshire Bankers sit on this advisor uh
board what do you have any objection to
Simply adding as he
suggested is there a reason to get rid
of a banker
um I think that there is um in this case
we have an instance where in essence
competitor institutions who want to do
business with the pool have seats on the
advisory committee for the pool
and so from my perspective um I think it
would be more appropriate for there to
be an additional member representing
cities and towns on the pool managing
the pool
versus uh a representative of entities
who want to do business with the pool so
I think it would represent a a step
forward to reduce the bankers seats to
one and add a an additional Municipal
representative follow cause of the
competition between the bankers and the
New Hampshire deposit yes I see it as a
conflict of
interest well thank you representative
long um so what municipalities have uh
funds that are covered by uh this
advisory committee and I asked that
because I'm just trying to understand
you know why it should be uh the
municipal management association rather
than the municipal associ iation uh and
if that makes some significant
difference in who gets selected to be
this person so the uh current advisory
committee of the pool does have one
representative from the municipal
Association at this time the municipal
Association could select a town or a
city manager a finance person or a
select person or U mayor or city
counselor so there's much more latitude
on the part of the municipal ass ation
and who they might appoint versus the
municipal management association where
you would get a manager with the kinds
of responsibilities I've
outlined um cities and towns counties
and other entities that qualify are able
to take advantage of the pool and uh
invest their money Garner High interest
rates um and that money stays liquid so
it's very important for the cash flow of
cities and towns sounds to be able to
have an entity like the
pool um and from my perspective um in
terms of the way the funds of the pool
are managed uh the statute that went
into effect last year does uh direct the
pool to evaluate and seek whether it's
possible whether it makes sense uh
fiscally to invest those funds in the
banks operating in New Hampshire at the
same time the pools responsibility is to
Garner the highest rate of return in a
safe and liquid way for the depositors
so the manager would represent the
depositors again versus the banks who
pool some a
followup um so I from my understanding
of your description of who's eligible to
be in the municipal Managers
Association uh assume that for example
Mayors are not eligible because they're
not exactly managers uh so I'm just
wondering and then I guess on the other
end I don't know if like small towns
even have managers so like what is the
the range of municipalities who you have
members from so um an elected official
would not be eligible to be a member of
the municipal Management Association of
New Hampshire um
however again the New Hampshire
Municipal Association might tap a mayor
to be its representative um members of
the MMA have to fulfill a set of
criteria and in essence we're looking at
individuals who are Town managers city
managers Town administrators even
administrative assistants who have
sufficient levels of responsibility in
their unique Community to qualify and on
a positive note we have an associate
membership as well in MMA
for those uh really small communities
that have a manager that has limited
responsibility but still wants to Garner
the educational benefits and um uh
networking that our association
provides representative L you had a
question no notk you um I had I'm
looking at the bill that lists the
members of this advisory committee and
it says there are two members by the New
Hampshire government Finance Officers
Association How would is that different
from your organization so um the
organization you just mentioned is um
another organization it's kind of a
parallel organization to the managers
but it's comprised of Finance officers
business managers business
administrators from towns and school
districts across the state and so in
that case you're getting somebody who
has a pure fiscal background versus
somebody who's in charge of the overall
management function of the town and who
also also will have some fiscal
background okay I will mention that in
many towns such as mine all of the
people with fiscal background are
elected and responsibility so that's
uh and they would not be eligible for
your organization but they would be
eligible for the other thank you
representative scitech I thought I heard
this that El elected officials aren't
eligible then representative uh blong
said something about asked a question he
said but a mayor could be put
in so but he's elected have did I miss
it would depend on which organization
was doing the appointing there
are the New Hampshire government Finance
officers the association of counties the
municipal Association the school boards
Association all can appoint a
representative and they can appoint an
Ed rep they can appoint whoever they
think will do the best
job so in this way there'd be a mix of
people on the board representative
dargy thank you madam chair uh do you
know how many members there are of the
mmnh they're approximately 130 I believe
minus okay other
questions yeah and we've got 234 cities
and towns so not not every Community has
somebody to
send some have smaller staffs and don't
have Professional Management in place
they rely on elected uh select people to
make those daily
decisions
okay any other
questions all right thank you very much
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Mike mlof I
represent pfm Asset Management I've been
working with the municipal Managers
Association for the last couple moments
talking about this bill I think one
thing that's important to remember is
this bill is not uh something that
Standalone it comes into an an
organization that is uh static the P dip
has been evolving over the last several
years beginning with a study committee
back in N 2022 that looked at the P dip
and said basically why is the banking
Department in charge of the P dip when
no other state or no other jurisdiction
that has a public deposit investment
pool has the banking Department we're
overseeing it so as they looked at the
situation they said it's time to make
the change to U create a more uh pool
that's consistent with the way all the
other pools in the country are running
so the study committee recommended
legislation which moved the overseeing
of the pep from the banking Department
to the state treasurer I handed out I
think
a I sent you over the email some
information relative to the timeline and
to what would happened to P but it's
important to recognize back in 1991 when
the PIP was put together the only group
in opposition to the pp was the New
Hampshire Banks
Association they were anly um or they
didn't reluctantly they put in
opposition to the original P dip because
the p dip uh is a direct competitor with
the banks the pp is looking to buy
financial instruments and products to
produce a return to satisfy their
shareholders the banks are looking to
sell products uh for their customers and
shareholders so when we looked at the
study committee and they changed the um
orientation to put it to the state
Treasures Office um office uh seemed to
be that it might be time to keep
evolving the pp to have it create more
of a uh organization that is in uh
synonymous with the rest of the
country's ped up so when we looked at
what might be a good idea to help is to
get a member of the municipal manag
Association onto the board to get more
influence from decision makers I think
the P dip and the bankers relationship
can best be ENC capitalized by an
analogy which is if all the cities and
towns had a a group a pooled group group
to buy Automobiles and they had an
advisory committee to advise them on
which automobiles to buy and they had
two four dealers on the advisory
committee that would be a conflict of
interest and the conflict of interest is
the idea or the um the origin of the
change in the overseeing of the P dip
when the study committee looked at the
New Hampshire Public deposit investment
pool they saw a direct conflict of
interest between the banking department
and the pp so the two Bankers on the pp
are inherently conflicted now we as we
talked about what should happen in the
um in this session was there's no
alternative to throw everybody throw the
bank is off but the alternative we're
operating today in this bill is to
continue the evolution of the pp by
adding uh a qualified member and the
municipal manag Association uh has a
member who's ready willing to serve on
the pp and to kind of
Wan that conflict of interest because
the advisory council is the group that
advises the treasurer on where to make
the Investments last session the um
there was B Senate Bill 553 where the
bankers who continue to um have a great
desire to do business with the pp and
let me stop for a second they can easily
do business with the pp by simpling
offering a product that is more
advantageous to the cities and towns
than the product that Pips offers
because the main main job of the public
deposit investment tool is to provide
the best return they can to their
investors so there is no prohibition for
a bank to do business with the pep but
when you put two Bankers on the board uh
and the banks are trying to do business
with the pp the inherent colc interest
is undeniable so the bill today simply
says let's make the change this
continued evolution of removing the
conflict of interest that the study
committee saw in the p
and replace at least one of the bankers
with a non-conflicted person who has the
best interest of the depositors uh there
is nothing that I would ever say that is
U to claim that any Banker is doing
something inherently wrong but when you
talk about conflict of interest it's the
appearance again if you had two four
dealers trying to sell trucks to the
cities and towns on a group it would be
a conflict of interest so as we look at
the evolution of the pp I think it makes
sense to take the next step step to put
RPD in line with every single public
deposit and pool in the country there is
no deposit pool in the country that has
any member of a board of directors or an
advisory committee that has a business
pool so it can if we continue this
Evolution you'll be back next year to
get rid of him entirely no the reason
I'm here today is the missable Managers
Association of Hampshire said we'd like
to be on the board unless somebody else
comes forward and says we'd like to be
on the board they can present their own
case but I'm not here to say if if that
was the case I would put it I wouldn't
put the bill in but a bill could come
before you to say take both the banks
out but that's not it today it's we have
a highly qualified as uh Mr Cel Sor but
a highly qualified group that says we're
ready willing and able to get on to that
board and the benefit is not only to the
board itself because the expertise but
it also reduces that uh inherent
conflict of interest which I don't think
uh it's pretty obvious seeing as we
started discussing the conflict of
interest back in 1991 finally got in
2022 and 2023 to recognize that there
exists one and now this has helped to
evolve the pep into what it really
should be which is a totally neutral uh
Advisory
board thank you a followup I'll be
watching you next year I hope I'm
back any other questions comments
concerns representative long so I take
your point about if you had two four
dealers but I would think if you had you
know a Ford dealer and a Chevy dealer on
the board the headbutting between them
would be uh helpful in
Illuminating the uh disadvantages of
each of their respective products so I
guess why does that Dynamic not occur
where you have two Bankers instead of
one well just then if we're going to
have a for in Chev deal we need Chrysler
Mercedes VW it just uh the bankers
inherently even the banker who he
mentioned is not working for Bank uh
their allegiance particularly a bank
who's employed and on the board their
first Allegiance under their basic
Employment contract is to their employer
and their employer's um goal is to sell
the products they can and return the
most money they can to their investors
and their shareholders um when you
sitting at the P their job is to find
the multiple different investment
vehicles that they can uh contract with
or buy so that all those shareholders
get the maximum return last year the
legislature uh wrangled with this whole
concept for several months and finally
came up with a uh a solution which said
yeah the PIP should strive to put money
in the banks but that doesn't mean they
should go looking for buying a product
that is not as good as the product so by
XYZ Financial that so the idea for the p
is still quite quite quite uh pointed
find the best products if the best
product is in a New Hampshire bank they
will get that product but again this
legislation is I look at the PIP as an
evolving entity and there's a timeline
started in 91 took us 30 took us 30
years to catch up with the fact that we
were doing it a little different than
other people but they changed it they
took the banking Department out the
banking Department Department in
testimony said yeah we have a conflict
and the bankers in themselves sitting on
the board I mean they didn't do anything
wrong to get on the board but as I look
in the history where in 1991 the bank is
strenuously objected to the
establishment of a pip uh just recently
the N excuse me the Alabama bank is
Association killed the bill in Alabama
to create a public deposit investment
poort because they compete for the same
dollars and when you compete for same
dollars against some else it's a
conflict of interest so again this is to
put a manager on that board who has
specialized knowledge and adds to the um
to the investment policy in a neutral
way um I don't think there's um uh the
rationale is do we have somebody to put
on the board uh there was a question
which do you mind expanding the board
and I would say if you look at the
history and we do have conflicts the
conflicts are there keeping another bank
on the board does nothing to reduce the
the conflict uh but uh again if if
somebody comes in next year who is a
highly qualified group or highly
qualified entity that says we'd like to
be on the board we have no conflicts I
would think that the committee would say
well that's exactly what the board
should be and it should know there is a
New Hampshire way but the the the
universal way across the country is
boards board of directors and Committees
of advisory committees are in absolutely
neutral there's nobody on those
committees that then goes out and says
Hey listen we got to cut 125 basis
points off this product we can sell it
to the um we can sell it to the public
deposit investment pool so it's um again
it's not a knock of the bank it's it's
the evolution of the of the PIP you can
just see it in the history they
recognize it's it's different made some
changes took it out of the banking
Department left the bank is hanging
there the bank is are a vestage of the
original P dip in 1991 if you was
forming a p dip today uh it's I guess
the bank would come in and testify
against it as they did in 91 uh maybe it
was a compromise you don't protest too
greatly and we'll put two of you on the
board I don't know how they got on the
board there's no legislative history on
it uh but I would suggest that this bill
improves the public deposit investment
pool in New
Hampshire thank you are there other
questions repres of sers thank you madam
chair is there any example that you can
give that the the public deposit
investment pool
did not make the amount of money they
should have or made wrong
investments in the well I don't have the
anal the analytics but I do know that
they've returned a solid return on
investment for the last 30 years they've
never a a a shareholder in the pool has
never lost any money so whether or not
uh they could have made more money but I
don't know but they are restricted to
certain uh highly uh secure Investments
and also shortterm I think the longest
term investment they have is 270 days so
doing commercial paper and all kinds of
different things but they can't they're
not looking for the maximum return
they're looking for the best return with
the most security so their performance
is judged U every quarter by the
advisory committee uh if they had a goal
of 4% uh and they came in at 3.5 then
they're going to have to say why uh but
they do report the returns every quarter
and they set their goals and they set
the parameters so the um and the P so
far has been it's been quite good over
the last 30 years and again it's it's
the municipal money and the trustees
money that is put in the pool is not
100% of a city Town's money it's a
portion that the the manager the
decision maker says we can get some
short-term interest on these funds that
are right now in in January 2025 not
dedicated to something the non-dedicated
funds if all the property tax money
comes in on Tuesday you've got uh a
million dollars you need to place to put
that to get the best return that's the
type of money the PDF handles it moves
that money and you can get that money
back in 24 hours it's very liquid so uh
how are they doing I think they're doing
pretty
good
okay other questions seeing none thank
you very much thank you m chair is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
469 all right seeing none I will close
the public
hearing and we have five minutes before
one you are the prime
what
e
all right welcome to Edna
uh opening the hearing on House Bill 570
Edwards thank
you uh thank you madam chair I'm uh
representative Jess Edwards I represent
the towns of Auburn Candia Chester and
Deerfield that's Rockingham District 31
um uh I'm uh
I also happen to be the chair of
division 3 Finance but but today uh more
than anything I've come in as a member
that's been appointed to the um
prescription drug affordability board um
as a speaker's appointment I think for
five years I've been on it for three and
a half years and I've been following the
PAB since uh its Inception since before
its
Inception so what uh what I've learned
uh from being a member of the of the
commission is that is that the initial
legislation needed some some tweaking so
I broke it into two parts um the uh
first one of the two parts you have here
today this is this is some a fine-tuning
of some organizational issues just to
clean up the statute for the most part
uh I'll I'll walk you through it the the
reasons for um um on on page what is
that number is that to we only have
there's only one the one page right of
text so so on that page um under Roman
numeral uh six uh starting on lines
three and running through six there's
there's uh or seven there's a couple of
tweaks to that and and the reason for
those are we realized as we were looking
at how much money the state spends on
prescription drugs that the initial
legislation uh cast slightly narrow net
and that our data would be better our
recommendations would be better honed if
we also include the Department of
Corrections like the Department of
Corrections didn't fit under the initial
definition but as we're looking at how
much money the state spends on
prescription drugs certainly we spend a
lot of money through Corrections and we
we wanted to bring that into the fold so
that's what that addition
is uh then down in Roman numeral what is
that is that a that's a four anyways
it's line
17 um through
20 uh the original charter basically
said that uh once elected chairman the
implication was they would remain
chairman until um their five years that
had expired so this was just to make
sure that we every couple years we took
a fresh look at the chair position to
make sure that the the leadership was uh
was appropriate so this is this this is
something that the current chair um uh
approved of he he he didn't win his
reelection but but he worked with the
senator Rosenwald and I to to come up
with this language and and he was okay
with that um then um down here starting
on lines 23 and running through
29 um for some reason my my colleagues
thought it was important to be very very
specific about our wanting the executive
director to uh feel like um in this case
a he he to have him feel like he had
some job security uh it had been set up
in my mind like every other state
employee that as long as you had money
and a job you you you had your
employment but but this was meant to
take a guy who's relatively young 30
years old or so and not from New
Hampshire and uh and and it was an
attempt to uh give the guy an
opportunity to feel like he had uh some
stability um so so that's that's what
that does um and I think I've I've
walked through the key parts of this um
I think it's just sort of some uh
administrative moving around of the deck
chairs um and I I I don't think it's
controversial it was done with key
leadership of the PAB uh in um in
conjunction with me
thank you are there any
questions represent Leon uh thank you
madam chair this is an area that I know
a little bit about but not a lot about
yeah um I guess first it sounds like the
granted Advantage plan wasn't even
included in this
information it's uh with the health
plans actually sorry that was just more
of a curiosity no under the first
definition all the Medicaid money that
that's actually the core source of the
data that we get from the Department of
Insurance uh data feeds okay thank you
sorry I have a couple questions
represent
zitech representative Edwards this is
beyond the scope of this Ed Edwards you
said Edgar but that that's all I didn't
mean to that's all right I knew who you
were talking to
um okay
uh the this is beyond the scope of this
bill but I'm going to ask you to comment
anyway from my perspective when this
things started it sounds like that might
have been a good idea but is this worth
a full-time board a full-time guy that
needs a job stability isn't this just F
fine-tuning how much drug work do you
need to be doing on a continuous basis
with the board and all of this seems
like a lot of apparatus
for uh fine-tuning something that once
I'm G to I'm going to be careful here um
I I I have U multiple personalities on
this one um I I have the division three
position of where I'm supposed to come
up with the funding for this I'm
actually on the commission uh I was one
of the early opponents of the bill uh
and uh I've I've worked or or with the
PAB to be fair and um and so so I'm
going to try to answer your question and
and and and walk some fine lines there
um the pdab is set up as uh as a board
that does not expire it goes as as long
as the legislation is in place uh it
relies on General funds for its two-year
budget cycle it's supposed to submit its
budget through the Department of Health
and Human Services where it's attached
um other than some basic uh soft uh
admin support the Department of Health
and Human Services provides no oversight
this is a a very
autonomous uh entity U by Statute um
it's uh specifically obligated to
develop an annual report to to to report
out on uh the statistics that are
determined to be relevant to our
prescription drug expenditure
and also potentially to provide
recommendations on how uh the purchasing
entities may get lower prices I mean
that's really where the the money is
supposedly in this board is in the value
of the
recommendations that are intended to let
payers not the board itself it has no
Authority but to make recommendations so
that the purchasers get better pricing
and that's how we're supposed to save
money
follow I'm really can't let you get away
with that um by which I mean
representative scitech I'm sorry uh
representative Edwards that's a fine
recitation of what the board's supposed
to be doing and I that I would support
that as a it doesn't matter what I
support right um is does that need all
this apparatus on a continuous basis
that's the Crux of my question
um I I think if you were to speak with
various people you would get uh various
responses to that um we uh had in law U
the conduct of a of a redundancy review
by the department of uh insurance and it
was a pretty thorough review and the
number of redundancies between this
board and other entities are pretty
significant lots of redundancies and the
key one is um related to reporting out
the 50 most expensive drugs by three
different categories that was already
being done by the department of
insurance and so it's a core piece of uh
this most recent annual report and and
then there was a lot of material that
sort of packaged it but um I think uh if
I were to say was this worth you know
500,000
as a report as a as a budget guy um I it
would be difficult for me to ask for
that kind of money for that kind of a
redundant
brother thank you um representative
Edwards we had I believe approved an
executive director for this right for
two years right right it's and and and
he got hired he didn't get hired
immediately but he did get hired and
he's we've been working for well over a
year now and and he and his
current position continues um at least
through the fiscal year and as long as
we continue to put money into the PAB
budget I I think he uh that position is
going to continue to be funded yes
follow
up so in other state agencies or other
entities like this we don't have bills
that say we want to fund a position I
mean now that it's set up it should be a
a financial decision and shouldn't be a
policy decision I mean that's my feeling
I can understand how you want to change
the definition of payer but then adding
you know a guarantee of a job in a
bill I I just want to is that what
you're is that what you're asking us to
do uh that's that's what the bill
proposes and the bill was a compr romise
with me and and and two other people uh
and I thought this was an odd thing to
put into a bill but in order to make
sure that we could provide the committee
with the bill from all three of us it's
there thank you representam uh thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
um it pricing of drugs and the cost of
drugs has really changed over the last
number of years it used to be really
competitive really Dynamic Marketplace
but a lot of that is sort of collapsing
in upon itself with everything being
based around the Medicaid rates and just
collapsing into itself um this seems
really complex given that uh pricing
negotiations have really changed and I'm
just curious
if if the value we get from having this
board is enough to offset some of the
other really important things that we do
in this state I mean we unfortunately
had to shut down a position to help
people from America core and peace core
because we can't afford to do that right
now and it just seems very hard for me
to justify putting in that POS the
executive director position for longer
when we're not sure about the value and
it has the redundancies how much do you
think it would cost if we were to remove
those parts that were found in the the
review that had the redundancies well uh
thank you for the question um I I may
not answer that directly but I I'd say
that uh the agency budget submission for
the next budget is at
$257,000 for uh the next year and I
think it's like 265 or something like
that in the second year and that money
includes funding for the executive
director and um and although I've not
done a formal review on it I suspect
that there's also money in there to um
to go to vendors to ask for additional
supplemental data to help us with our
analysis uh there may be some money in
there for a contract person's because
it's a lot of work for the executive
director um and could you just remind me
of the key key part of your question
because I think I just missed it um the
key part was just trying to understand
oh is it worth it is it Val it's worth
it um what the price is and if if there
would be a way to trim it down to
something that's more that better
recognizes the the pressures that we're
facing today I I I would say that there
are unlimited wants and limited
resources and that this budget cycle is
going to make that painfully apparent to
every legislator because we know that
historically our if we continued with
our expenses that that would exceed the
available uh um revenues and so we have
very difficult decisions to make where
we have to make those kinds of tradeoffs
and one person's judgment on on utility
and value is going to be a little bit
subjective uh and so um so I I I I I
guess I would leave it to every member
of the committee to say um is it worth a
quarter million dollars a year to get in
a report a very Nic looking report uh
data that we could get directly from the
anyways good question
and as a followup um do you know if
there's any specific harm that would
come from removing removing the funding
from this and removing the the PAB here
okay so we we we um the the chair and I
came in late after the chair had
struggled mightily former representative
Gary Merchant who many people know he he
did just a great job uh in a volunteer
role kind of standing up the pdab and
trying to get it going and uh we really
were just slogging in the mud until they
could hire an executive director and it
was after the that full-time person
became employed and focused that we
started to make some some gains and like
I said the annual report's a beautiful
thing there's a lot of information in it
it you know most of it is not
statutorily required but um but if we
were to cut the budget much you would
cut into uh the ability to
continue the employment of the executive
director fairly quickly right because
you can tell that's about 150 of the
$250,000 so I I I think if you if you
were to look if you were looking to
reduce this it would either be uh that
that 100,000 above the pay is is the
play area and if you cut below that you
may as well shut down the pdb because
without the executive director it can
produce nothing in my opinion follow and
as my one last followup um actually the
former representative you mentioned is
one of my favorite people um absolutely
and my big question here is is this
something that was functioning as well
as it was just because it was in such
capable
hands well you know the the former
representative his uh continuity in the
board continues he's still the chair of
the PAB uh and I'm sure he's watching
and listening right now and I'm so sorry
uh for for not being a stronger
supporter of the pdab I just I've just
always worried about the redundancy in
them especially now with the new
Administration I think the whole
prescription drug environment's changing
I think uh there are multiple states in
the nation that have pabs where I where
if we're looking for recommendations on
what to do I think it may be better just
to hire somebody to collect and
aggregate the state report and look for
the three or four great ideas that would
work here in New Hampshire I I I think I
think we could um achieve the important
objectives of the board in a different
way and I I I feel like I've really
strayed because this bill was intended
to just be a a cleanup um and a
reorientation of U how the PAB is
structured and so I I'm happy to answer
questions it's just further a field than
what I thought thank you okay
representative pearon thank you madam
chair thank you he representative
Edwards um you know as
a as in existence right the drug
affability board was created with a
charge right was created with an i you
know like this is what we want you to do
has when you refer to the the changes in
the invol in the evolvement of of
prescription drugs in in the nature of
that Universe does does this simply need
then the charge to be modified or
updated as to what their
responsibilities and expectations are
that there are components of that in the
second bill I I had mentioned that I had
split these up and this this bill was
really meant to be sort of a cleanup of
the organizational structure the second
bill is going to a different committee
and it's escaping me right now and that
sort of detail is in the in the second
Bill gotcha okay
thank you other
questions I I would I would hope like if
the legislature were to move in and and
and um do something dramatic with the
pdab th this portion of the bill is fine
it's the other bill that I think the a
lot of these
questions are are maybe fit better but I
do appreciate the opportunity to address
them in in front of this committee thank
you for the information all right
lean thank you Madame chair uh for the
record my name is Peter Lehman I
represent the towns of Peterboro and
Sharon I appear before you today against
this
legislation like representative Edwards
uh I have been following pdab for
probably now what four years originally
um represented Merchant and others came
before The Joint legislative fiscal
committee that representative Edwards
and I serve on looking for us to provide
the funding to establish this board that
request was rejected and we suggested it
should be followed through the normal
budget process and go to a policy
committee and not have the joint
legislative fiscal committee make such
decision I certainly think that
representative scitec got it right with
what he said I'll add to that that
there's redundancy here there's no
oversight we already know the insurance
department does the same thing and in a
year that we are strapped for funds to
me spending $500,000 on PB when we've
got another agency within state
government again the insurance
department doing the same thing is the
reason why I oppose the bill and I'll be
happy to take any questions Madam chair
thank you are there any questions
represent blam uh thank you madam chair
and thank you representative lean um do
you know if anything would need to be
done within the insurance department to
allow them to collect the information
from other states if we didn't have the
pdab I believe they already have that
Authority and do it
already
you is there anyone else who wishes to
570 okay seeing none I'll close the
what
that yes I we've had a request for a
caucus so if the Democrats could use the
office and those gentlemen could step
out we'll uh see what we want to do
things
e
okay welcome back we're we are starting
an executive session on House Bill
469 the membership of the public deposit
investment pool
does someone have a
motion I'll move
that's would you wish to speak to your
motion thank you um Madam speaker I I am
in support of this
bill no no I'm oh did I say Madame chair
sorry no I mean I don't have a problem I
want to know what we
no not today thank you Peter it's just
been a long day um so the I'm in support
of it and I think that this is a well
thought out Bill and it balances the
authorities among the different groups
and
will be purposeful in its Mission okay
representative Schmid do you wish to
speak well they think it's an
improvement in the current situation
which is thank
U or an organization that's already
working right it's a good idea
advantages our citizenry small towns
especially to have the money invested
bringing in as much revenue as possible
and people on the board think it's this
is a better way to to do the business
that they have been doing so duh has
vote for it okay thank you any other
comments representative uh I'd like to
see how this evolves into next
year evolution is always an interesting
process but the
um from what I know about last year's
Bill the users of the pp are very happy
with it and they would have and having
another user on the board
one of the more sophisticated users at
that seems like a very reasonable thing
to
do and having two out of 40 Bankers as
opposed to one out of 130 Municipal
managers seems like a a better
position anyone
else okay the motion is ought to pass by
representative grota and the clerk who
call the role representative uh Vice
chairman Leon yes the clerk vot yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey
I that's
yes representative shim yes
representative sers
yes representative Gro yes
representative Schmidt
I
breing uh representative Davis
yes representative Dary yes
representative Howard yes representative
re
yes representative long yes the chair
yes I guess
that's 13
nothing
okay motion passes 13 to
nothing representative citex repr is
correct this not adding should it be 14
what I'm doing it
again it passes significantly many to
zero how about when you talk about
consent and then we'll get a I think I
think it should be I'm does anyone
object to
consent okay thank you representative
broa at your very earliest
convenience
and and that's it I the other bills we
heard today aren't quite ready to EXA so
close the executive session and see you